[Music]
with only three rounds left and all to
play for
eight of the best chess players on the
planet were back and hungry for victory
a brilliant win by anish giri eliminated
the hopes of former challenger
while ian nepomniacci's grind out game
against wang hao
helped him maintain his slim half point
lead over his main rival
the competitors are desperate for points
in the biggest tournament of the year
penultimate round coverage of the
candidates in yekaterinburg
starts now
[Music]
[Music]
welcome everybody to the candidates
tournament being played
at the beautiful hyatt regency in
yekaterinburg
we're determining who is going to
challenge world champion magnus carlson
at the end of the year and my name
is alejandro ramirez i'm here with grand
masters
yasser sarawan and maurice ashley
guys it's been a fascinating tournament
a long one that even started
last year ending up this year but it
is coming down to only a few players now
absolutely it is
and hello alejandro and maurice hello
everyone good afternoon
as we are in the penultimate round of
play what i like to call the
championship rounds
and really it's come down to a contest
of two
would be challengers maurice and that's
napo
and unease great tension-filled
tournaments and these last two rounds
it's about the nerves
it always is and i consider the
penultimate round to be the
real money round that's the one you set
yourself up for going
into the last round you can't bomb here
and hope for the best
in the last round and the tension is
high
a dream come true for a new discussion
waiting in the wings now
who will it be who will be able to stand
the intense pressure of the last two
rounds
let's take a look at the standings there
as we have
of course as
the leader of the tournament and he's
followed
closely but not as closely as we think
as we're gonna about to see
by anish giri and of course with an
outside chance
is maxine vasherla graf as we'll see the
pairings are important for him
but guys it's just about these three
gentlemen
everybody else pretty much eliminated
from the tournament yes they could
improve their standings but in the
candidates
there's only one place that they care
about and that's top
place speaking of that matchup between
nepomiacci
and giri that's giving nepal the
tiebreak edge on top of the point edge
so remember
yanaponya should defeat it with the
black pieces like anishigiri
in a beautiful english in which nepal
sat down on the board
refuted anish's preparation and came
out victorious this is not only giving
him a half point lead
over the dutch but the head to head that
is the first tie break in the candidates
which means that
essentially anish is a point behind
nepalniacci he has to make up more
than just the half point difference that
he has
that's a tough task for sure but is he
up to it he'll have to prove
that he is world championship material
the format of course a double round
robin
it started last year and we are
finishing with the second half of
the double round robin this year very
much
classical chess we know it's a hundred
minutes to start the game
throughout the entire game you get an
extra 30 seconds
but at move 40 you get an extra 50
minutes and then move 60 you get another
15 minutes something that we've seen
quite a few times especially here in the
second half of
uh the round robin of course a price
point of 500 000
euros but nobody really cares about that
we care about the ticket
to fight against uh magnus carlsen
this schedule we have potential playoffs
on the 28th but those probably will not
happen i do not see
a chance for the mathematical tiebreaks
to be equal
which means we'll be finishing the
tournament off with the next two rounds
the ones that we have right now
and the ones that we have tomorrow and
that will be it will be
knowing who is playing against magnus
carlsen
later this year thank you alejandro and
let's just
jump right into oh sorry
and let's take a look first at the road
ahead for the top
three with maurice yes we've been
talking about
the two stars then clearly no question
about it odds are that they will be able
to win
but there's one other player a joker if
you will
in the pack of cards that might be able
to change things around so let's take a
look at all three
starting with maxine vashi lagrave we've
seen him
just have disaster disastrous results
here but
he's still in it with a shout it's
possible
he's got to defeat nepo today with the
black pieces
he's done it before at least defeating
nepo in this event
can he create a probable distraction and
blow the whole tournament wide open
remember his results against depot six
to one
he's dominated this opponent so nepo
knows
don't screw around you might lose but
the odds are not great
and if he does win against nippo he'll
probably still have to win
in the last round against wang hao odds
are not great but
for the title who cares about odds and
speaking of one of the players whose
odds look pretty good actually
is anise geary he's got two big games to
close it out this one
against grishard who he drew in the
first half
probably needs to win with the black
pieces now and alex senko
the lowest rated player in the event and
he's defeated him in the first half
he'll look to do the same as well to
really have a chance
at this one but chance schmann's throw
that
out the window the player with destiny
in his hands
is yon nipomnichi he's got the lead
he's got a bigger tie break lead in fact
and all he's got to do probably is trial
right now a win against maxine
and all of russia will be cheering no
question about it
then he'll have dingler in in the last
round will ding
show up will the real ding loren please
stand up in that last round
i don't know if he's gonna want to given
that he has no chances at all
but it's nepo the number three
new number three player on the planet
right now
and he can really show that he has it
has what it takes he has a great record
by the way against magnus carlsen
so magnus will have something to prove
against him but he's got to get it done
two rounds to go for history in his
hands guys and it's looking like
nepo should take it if there was a bet i
think we all
would line up with the young russian
and let's take a look at the pairings uh
alejandro
absolutely it's this maxima sherlock
graph game that's gonna keep
our attention and probably we will be
keeping a close eye on that grisha geary
game as geary definitely tries to make
up the difference it's almost a must-win
game
for him to round off the pairings we do
have wong hao against fabiano carrana
not the most relevant for the first full
position while alexenko is playing
dinglin
definitely not the most interesting for
the top position but we'll keep an eye
on those games
as well and yasser let's go straight
into it take us around the horn but
there are some games that we
absolutely have to look at absolutely
let's jump into our most salient games
that's between grishok
and anish geary this came from a cappa
blanca
variation of the queen's indian defense
uh grishok can can lead with either hand
e4 or d4 and after seeing what
anish did in the previous round in the
sicilian ah
grisham said now that let me play a
queen pawn opening
capo blanca variation is typified with
this move c5
not it's not it's an intriguing way of
getting an imbalance
but i don't really favor you know moving
a potential attacker of the center the c
pawn usually goes to c5 attacks the pawn
on d4
now it's sitting on the square b4 and
this variation so far
sasha's played it very well it's just
he's traded a lot of the pieces this
move h5
is a little controversial i guess you
want black to
do something usually black plays for e5
maybe rook b8 as well as b5 but h5 was a
bit of a surprise
[ __ ] fighting the type of move that
gary sees his chances
of playing the world championship
disappearing
let's play h5 let's make something
happen
there is a lot of pressure to create
something with the black pieces and the
annoying side that gristrok has done so
far against him
he's had us such a solid approach to
this opening
yeah that's really the problem if we go
back i'm more familiar with
ideas of rook b8 and b5 looking to
swap off this b6 pawn potentially
making some nice little tricky ideas
of b5 queen b7 possible but you're right
if
black just basically tries to sit on the
position and
accepts further trades his chances of
winning
keep going down and down and down with
each trade so the move h7h5 says
okay i'll look for some kind of counter
chances
over there on the king side even though
in a different circumstance i might play
rook b8 knight c2
the idea behind white strategy is very
clear he wants to try to keep this
knight as far out of the game as he can
knight on a6 if you stay permanently
there you'll be
worse rook b8 defends the pawn again
maybe starts to say okay i want to play
for knight c7 and b5
sasha made a very big decision this move
e2
e4 excuse me i wanted to say that
in one of the model games that i first
remember back
in the 80s by alexander beliavsky by the
way
big al as we called him uh put his pawn
on e3
his queen on f3 rook on b1 pawn on e3
doubled rooks
and kept black under pressure this move
e2
e4 is a big one because after the
move e6 e5 the strategic
howler like a really really bad move
that you just simply never
want to make is the move d5 the move d5
gives up this gorgeous c5 square
and the knight instead of being forlorn
and out of the game and you know
stuck in the corner not bothering anyone
suddenly
is a raging monster on the c5 square so
you don't want to play
d5 but okay with this move e5
black is looking to win the c5 square
well sasha says i have my ideas too
i'm looking to win control over the d5
as well as f5 square yeah you you'll
have a good night
congratulations but then again maybe
well hold on if i'm not plundering upon
then again
uh so will i i'll put my knight on f5 or
d5
you'll have a good night i'll have a
good night too overall
i think the game's about even but i do
prefer white's
uh slight space and edge let's just jump
into the
other game of our tournament leader and
that is between
nepo and mvl mvl approach to this game
from the very beginning was it's all or
nothing
i'm going to play something that's
non-theoretical
that's likely to be bad for me as black
but i'm going to force you to play
originally
and i'm just trying to get you on your
own
to my eyes it looks like black has a bad
version of a king's
indian defense having said that we know
that king's indian defenses are those
types of
uh positions where if black ever lands a
punch
a big punch on the king's side it can be
a knockout blow
i like nepo's position a lot having said
that
um there's still a lot of play in this
position we just saw by the way
e4 a big time move
followed by f5 f4
trying to get a pawn wedgie going on
the king side thoughts guys
well to me this position may be the best
that maximus had since the opening began
i mean yeah it wasn't a good opening at
all
it was not at all but here
and e4 by nepo you've got to think nepo
was happy with the draw he's thinking of
droids just fine
but now that you've waved the flag in
front of me that red flag
i've got to be a bull and go win this
event a win
almost a short which is not 100 clinch
it's not
mathematical geary could win and of
course he could lose that is nepo
tomorrow and giri wins again
and he's overtaken but those odds are
it's just
way too long and and fanciful a win
now could totally seal the deal and you
want to do that in the second to last
round
that's what you set yourself up for when
you play the initial phase of the
tournament
and i think that maksim is hoping that
the pressure of
the should i or should i should i kill
this guy now should i go for it
or should i keep playing solidly might
cause
yan to waffle a little bit and maybe
have a hiccup along the way
so upon an f4 that's as aggressive upon
as we can imagine him having
go back a few moves yes to show the
initial part of the position where we
were
looking at it going ew i mean back when
the bishop
first hit f4 this position here
you could not imagine a black pawn on f4
after rook to e8
as a matter of fact like how are you
getting your pawn to f4 upon the e5
all that how do you sneak past white's
pawn center
we were liking other moves for nepal
right now he did choose
the very specific and intriguing trait
of this dark squared bishop
uh and just a few moves it didn't take
much after rook b1 to e5
to happen the knight dropping back f5 to
happen
and now after queen f6 in this
continuation
he switched back from the queen side and
now over to the center
and allow this move f4 this is some
humdinger of a game this doesn't feel
like a draw at all it feels like
somebody's going to win chances favor
white
but maxine might be feeling like i hear
you
but i'm starting to get a little
foothold somewhere
maybe there's a chance for me all right
i agree that
this is for max seems something you want
to see counter attacks here counter
attacks there i got my pawn to f4 i'm
not sure where it's going
but i can make some threats my question
is
uh does c5 work immediately i keep
trying to look at this move but
i'm not really sure how you defend and
knight b5
was my point
you know this is very very specific uh
plan and uh sacrificing upon and then
the idea is
since you're threatening queen take c5 i
really
don't have a choice alejandro i kind of
gotta
take and play this yeah i wasn't even
sure which knight to take because i
think i can also take on uh
on b5 i wasn't really sure which one d6
knight b3
kind of things i'm not sure if i'm this
needs to be calculated out but
right it could also just be bad for
black thrilled if i saw that as black
like that's as good as the position ever
got but this looks like
is it white just kind of taking over
here
this looks like a really really good
compensation
for a pawn yeah this pawn's not going to
survive long right
yeah i'm thinking bishop h3 i'm thinking
the rook
yes okay so we're up upon you're saying
you're willing to
you're also sacking an exchange as well
i don't know
what i don't know if i could do it but
we might as well just show it uh it's
got to be on the board i'm not a
person who likes to take these kind of
exchanges to be sure
but let's just look at it at least nice
c3
knight c3 take on b7 is the plane
yeah and then take on d1 and now d7 is
hanging
right all right here we go now nothing
to block with so you have to move and
the take on c6 with the pawn looks
horrific
hh
okay we could come back as to where the
king could move because
uh wherever the king moves it looks a
little bit awkward but okay here
okay but rook a1 rook a1 is the
counterfeit a1
that's so let's see
what do you do about this whoa i heard
your queen is guarding the f2 point so
important i can be specific he could
take on g3
and rook f8 and you better land
oh boy you're coming back on defense
hmm yeah this doesn't feel extremely
clean i have to say no and there's a and
there's a queen of three
there uh ooh but knight f2 here
nine of knight them queen e3
check no okay then there's a queen
f2 here you know um knight takes i could
play queen f2 no
although you do have trade and knight f
no
yeah this doesn't work right i'd have
seven i don't know
because where's your that's a little bit
king g7
it's a little bit weird let's see
okay i'm just saying that c5 is the
c5 is the kind of move alejandro that
for me while it feels good it looks good
it's something like you want to punish
your opponent it's also one of those
things like we've just seen like
something couldn't be
re rebound against you if it works it's
like
you know mazel tov but if it doesn't
it's sort of like why did i
throw everything away to my mind what
i'm doing as white or what i think
nepo should be doing is just limiting
the activity of those two pieces
the knight on a6 and bishop on b7 and
saying
look those are your problem child
you know like you figure out how to get
them back into the game what i'm going
to do is i'm going to go
92 preparing your c5
but i'm not giving you nothing i'm
giving you absolutely
nothing uh and that's what he did and
maybe this is a prelude to capturing
capturing that way we've got e5 ideas
too
so 90 oops excuse me that was a
milestone but this is so 92 by
uh white this move is very solid and
it's one of those willie or won't you
situations i told you
is he going to go for the win or isn't
he because
here black does have the move
c5 himself
and black black was lacking breaks for a
long time but this one
if that the move e4 i'm going to tell
you the move e4
it may have been a good move i'm not
going to say it's not but whenever i see
this move
i think about what the potential minus
the bishop on b7 we know
is crying i mean just when am i ever
going to get into the game
someday d6 might happen a bishop to c8
that day looks far off into the future
but the move e4 does very specifically
bury your bishop as well
the bishop on g2 is weakened and
the f file this little sensativo on f3
with the pawn you weaken the
f3 square so there's some pluses but
there's some minuses as well
and this moves c5 stopping your c5
and getting the b4 square for the knight
it's not exactly the the boom hidden
crush
that we we thought was happening about
eight maybe six moves ago
six moves ago yes you played a move like
bishop takes knight on d6
you should point that out to the
audience a strategic concept that you
play which i thought was
a fantastic trade a not counterintuitive
trade for a lot of people giving up a
bishop for a night
uh it was it was in this moment you said
let's take this piece
and whatever he takes back with let's
see him figure out how this bishop on a6
on on b7 i was thinking let's get to a6
somehow but
let's see how this bishop on b7 ever
ever ever gets into the game
if we never never never trade off the
d-bonds
how does the bishop on b7 b7 ever get in
the game
it just looks like a horrible piece and
this felt like some some kind of action
the c5 moved by white earlier instead of
e4
that seemed very active as well as you
as we go down this line
and i think there's a point here uh
right
right here c5 instead of e4 has a
a tactical point knight a6 c5
takes takes takes knight b5 and you
remember the line with c6 so it's uh
takes on b5 queen takes
and now c6 doesn't work because the
bishop is breathing
life on the long diagonal so pawn takes
runs into rook takes suddenly and it's
two pieces for the rook
i'm not sure if this is better winning
oh it's winning for sure
yeah so that e4 move
followed by the knight e2 i'm saying
netboy's not exactly saying come get him
kill him destroy him he's played a
couple of solid moves and i'm just
wondering
is he i'm not going to say he's
buckling under the pressure but he's
certainly feeling it and he may not want
to take any risky chances
with the most aggressive moves that we
can of course we're analysts so
yeah yeah well that's a
well that's a very important point that
you just
mentioned there with the ambush on this
long diagonal with rook takes b5 because
it does
buttress what you said alejandra that c5
might just have been
a huge advantage white because if i
can't
capture twice on c5 what am i doing i'm
dropping back with my knight i hate
these types of positions where you know
i can just
i hate these doesn't cease to get in
there i'm sorry maybe
c6 is even winning just winning e6 looks
crushing you can't take twice
because knight is just in b5 horrible
oh this is terrible this is absolutely
terrible
if i can go c4c5 c6
all with gain of tempo i mean it's just
terrible so maybe
maybe there was a clear miss here guys i
mean knight b5
haman hamana what what am i supposed to
do if i
can't play knight takes b5 do i now
there's so many things hanging i think
you have to right
yeah but this looks oh this looks
horrible
uh so c5 looks like it might have just
how many he stacked upon his knight
knight d6
could we can we continue that line to
just check uh
so with c5
uh i i don't want to play this move
after just play uh
knight takes b5 looks force queen takes
and knight d6 hanging c7
bishop is so bad bishop oh
bishop a6 hitting a pawn six
oh boy yeah rugby sex starts to hurt
right
yeah that that that's knight
now you're just i'm not i'm not i'm out
of a pawn anymore
you're not upset you're down upon you're
down
no stop wait wait wait when i get to c3
hold on let's finish the line rookie
seven oh
just gonna keep hustling dead hustling
away keep going
queen c6 that does allow knight c3 and
in a check with that c6 pawn looks like
a1 is
completely winning
terrible looking sends a shiver up the
spine
but it does reconfirm your point that
c4 c5 a move definitely on white's
agenda
it's what he wants to do e2 e4 i hear
you guys what you're saying about this
bishop
you know kind of getting stuck but you
know it's the funniest thing
there's these bishops i like to call
them the
accelerated fianchetto they cannot uh
poke their head out to the other
diagonal as well
and eyeball this pawn but it's e5 but c5
yeah no i understand that you know
obviously this big center but c5 by
black though to shut things down
for that bishop well first of all does
it shut things down or does it open up
the position
for white like i take you got to take
right you got to take with the pawn now
can i do something to take advantage of
uh this kind of loose night i don't know
something like this to try to
i don't know maybe on a good day uh
clipping on
this just looks slightly less horrible
but it still looks horrible for black
slightly less horrible that's nice
it's not okay let's keep going trade
queens looks like
wait wait i don't have to trade queens
because i can take with the king what
about g5 instead sorry let's back up g5
if i don't have to trade
you don't want to hang my yes you don't
want to happen if i traded
the knight would be knight f3 comes
later yeah knight of three comes with
tempo
so knight of three right now is very
strong no
same move right because knight takes e4
i have rook d7
you cannot play rook e7 oh that's nasty
rook d7
maurice that's no no your knight only
two is hanging
what do you mean my knight an e2 is
hanging oh you mean like
here here the plane goes somewhere
yeah h6h8 where i don't know let's
if it's wrong we'll pick another one but
let's go okay
yeah and what you're saying is
that's okay oh uh i mean the musician is
hanging still
the position exactly that's the problem
remember
a life scenario where the catalan
players live for such bishops
so what we're saying in a nutshell each
and every one
of you watching is uh
black's in trouble black is in trouble
and maybe i want to keep fighting
oh no i'm sure you're going to get f3
you have to but how do you fight c5
looks not fun but i can't allow c5 as
black well that's the whole point
that's what maurice is saying he's
saying i mean c5 is going to kill me i
better
i better play it myself before you do
and i'm not even sure that this is a
variation you really want either
because i'm threatening to take i've got
ideas of
here we will pretend that the knight on
b4 gives me enough
obviously you're gonna think about
sacking for this yeah at this point
just give up the dark squares right i
don't think i take
i don't think i take on f4
i don't know where my compensation is
but i try
i try to find it well it's not it's
not in the uh the beautiful the beauty
is bishop on b7 that
that that bishop on b7 at the moment is
just
actually a tactical target so uh
what i wanted to do by the way just to
finish the thought was to capture on e5
and get my doggies rolling
push baby e5 yeah that's what i was
thinking too
so in fact you know maybe maybe
this is you you end up forcing me to
play this one
no this looks terrible too by the way
let's go uh
back to the game of anish and grishak as
as usual well what's the time
on a grishak's clock 26 minutes okay
26 minutes an eternity we left it yeah
for grishik that's true queen to d3
knight to c7 as we know that knight is
the problem rook ab1
knight to e6 problem solved
yep well brishook has been playing i say
beautiful chess just like you see the
way
he's moving his pieces around putting
them on the perfect squares it looks
like every time and
he is playing the class chess of this
event so far his problem
he lost to nepo in round one that's all
you gotta say like
you shouldn't have lost to the guy in
round one or else this would have been a
completely
different situation without any quote
he's a half a point behind just
could have could have easily made this
uh his event
but that loss in round one has cost him
but he's been playing just
sterling chess so far in these first
uh five rounds this being the sixth can
he pull off a victory and keep his hopes
alive slim hopes to be sure but if he
does win this game
and and nepo also wins
there is still a mathematical chance
that he can pull it off he could
hope for dingleryn to show up and beat
nepo in the last round while he takes
care of
kiril alexenko he hopes but at least
he's trying and keeping a
mixed up position here i like white to
be sure
but black has his chances i think we all
agree with that
white slightly to be prepared prefer
look at this rook on b5
stronger center easier plan i would say
my rook's going
to come to b1 and i'm going to pressure
your b6 pawn
yes he's playing well yes he's not in a
lot of trouble
but we all prefer white in this position
right absolutely yeah and i think that's
the way of putting it is
is white for choice but i do think that
black has
to return whether it's now or in
the not too distant future of getting
some counter play with h5
h4 also i wanted to say guys
obviously we reckon that
the challenger is going to be either
nepo or a niche
and i've got to say this tournament
these two players are deserving
challengers i mean if you look at those
line scores
what onisha's achieved in the last i
don't know 10 rounds or so
it's been fantastic and nepo has played
great chess too
so whoever emerges as the challenger is
going to be a very deserving one for
sure
right they both only lost one game
all right right nepal lost to maximum
maximum seven
seven anisha hasn't had anybody taste
his blood since round one
yeah and it's not just right it's not
just been that uh it's not like
uh they've been gifted anything they've
earned it look at those lines look at
that
score this one here is tremendous from
round six you play like this from round
six
is that slow start the loss in four
draws in a row but from round
six four wins out of seven that's a
boss tournament getting it that's like
a hello i'm trying to win this thing and
he might have another win in him to come
so a tremendous event nobody's going to
be talking about
anish giri draw master after the way
he's played the first
third of this year without any question
he's showing that he plans to
be a contender for years to come and
nepo
you know you see the loss in the middle
but his line scores
even better five wins here
with the one sandwich loss in the middle
and round seven
an absolutely spectacular tournament no
question about
it this is the line score of a
challenger this is when you look at it
you say
this is supposed to be the guy who does
it all and look at this
number eight and a half eight and a half
eight and a half
and then a nine this is what it normally
takes
to win a candidate this is what it's
taken to win the last four candidates
nepo right now with a victory in this
round will go
plus five which will
give him is it nine points yeah he'll
jump
up uh from eight he'd have nine with a
round
to spare he could have the best
candidates result
uh in the last of the last five and
that's saying something
when you see the players who have uh
actually uh
been been celebrated on that list
and it's just incredible incredible
yeah i think amazing performance value
both players
you you can't be extremely surprised
when you think top players in the world
you think
easily jan nepamyachi and yushkiri and
the ratings have been reflecting it
they're currently the number three and
four players
in the world right behind fabiano carona
and magnus carlson
and they've been consistent and this is
something you need for these tournaments
anish hasn't lost since round one nepo
lost that one game
against mvl a year ago but in this
second
half he's shown up he's not been in
trouble it's not like
he's it's not like he's been gifted
these points right
you could say that mvl was gifted half a
point by dingleran
because that position was so
overwhelming
but when was nepo ever in trouble in the
second half
when was anish honestly really in
trouble in this
or the last half i would say anish could
even have scored
more if you think that the absolutely
winning game that he had against fabiano
caron in the first half
that's love in which he was just
crushing uh his opponent and
let him go i mean little things like
that might come back to haunt them but
they've shown
by far the best chess of the event it's
not just
the points that they got two very very
deserving
uh challenges and i think that anish i
didn't check but i think with his
his victory both of them must have
jumped
oh look at this nepo is at 27.97.3
on the live rating
from 2800 huh one win if he beats
if he beats maxime today he's a 2800 but
he beat the 15th or 16th
i'm not sure which number he becomes but
he crosses 2800 for the first time and
we'll
we'll say well we got two 2800s playing
for the world title
that's what we want to see anish giri is
at 27
91.5 he's gained 15 and a half
rating points 15 and a half rating
points
in five rounds right
that's like are you serious yeah
tremendous
jump uh from where he was he surpassed
dingler in
who's now the number five player in the
world and
grishok aronian is at 27.81 grishiker
2770
i'm just going down the list i don't
where's
maxim is at number 15 now he really
still
having dropped a number of points and
he's dropped
below players like where poor farugia
is that the young ferocious number 12
ahead of maxime
dominguez perez i mean maxime we know
elite top 10 player having a disastrous
tournament here
and just shedding rating points and uh
it's a combination right because he has
a bad tournament here he just comes from
a bad tournament
in viking's a so exactly just maybe he's
points
yeah he's dropping points kind of left
and right in the last couple months
so the deserving players guys it's very
clear it's either nepo
or anish nobody's going to complain if
either one makes it
absolutely just taking a gander
at the game between carol and ding laren
because dingler in
i mean underperformed his ratings uh
for this candidates that's for sure and
ding has just sacrificed it it's one of
these joko piano positions
where black gets in the move d5 and
white plays e4 takes d5
and white tries to say this pawn on e5
is weaker than this pawn on d3
and when we were coming on air
i kind of felt the position was was
actually balanced when we got here
and these last few moves i'm thinking
hey man i just snacked upon where
is the compensation so clear the cobwebs
for me guys where do you think the
the compensation is after for example a
move like well
double the rooks on the e file i'm
assuming knight c3 was not playable
right
on the last turn yeah
knight takes c3 okay pause for just a
second
so this guy is hanging and bishop d4
is i guess the main point
yeah it's the main point i'm not too
happy if i have to play bishop takes e6
f takes e6 but maybe i'm okay with that
the the difference of course the point
is that bishop t4
kind of skewers everybody on that
diagonal right everybody kind of
everybody but the queen is geometrically
poised
to uh to be ready for this but this
bishop c4 does uncover
an attack the question is can i just
take on e6 first
and somehow the queen does defend
everybody
including the f2 pawn by the way
including the f2 pawn right
so in this position there's no uh
trigger
yes exactly the the rook doesn't get
uh all right but let's continue queen c3
i'm sorry i
started with bishop takes on f2 instead
yeah that's what i was wondering rick
takes e5 knight takes c3
bishop takes e6 f takes e6 queen takes
c3 bishop takes f2
that's one pawn and a tempo yeah you
have to go to e2 to cover d4 if you go
to e4 i have bishop d4
but there here after 92 i was kind of
hoping
that i have rook takes d3 and why don't
you
something hangs i don't know it is a
piece though
i mean that looks like a great idea
bishop bishop to g3 check is coming
right you're guarding your rook now but
boy this
looks this looks like you're hanging on
by a thread because g2 could hang
okay what if i check you what happens
here
well i've got well i've got two
uh two pieces for well i'm a piece up
for the moment but uh if you take on
e5 i'll have two pieces for an exchange
no
you're pinned i'm not gonna take it i
don't need to take let me play rook d2
you look to d2 my thread is to take on
e2
exactly and this
this one yes
okay so you have rook c4 what if i play
rook d5 now you can play bishop d6 yeah
rookie five mission d6 holds
everything dog i'm like
six and if i play rook two
nah e2 you play bishop rook to e2 you
play bishop d6 anyway
yep rook c5 yeah i i
really count me in on rook c5 i like
that one
man this barely held on so close but
if we go back i love these two well i'm
sure
that they are a bit i'm just saying that
that i mean
that's back there i don't know how much
time we're going to spend
on this position i just wanted to get to
the current position
and i just wanted to ask you guys i
guess
you're looking at the same knight c3
bishop f2
you need to do something like that to
justify your position
right or yeah i can't
i don't quite see it the compensation i
mean i don't either that was why i was
asking so you guys think
that the move c7 c6 uh
by ding laren was probably
um no i don't know i mean knight takes
e3 might not work right
we it's a lot of variations to be
considered and we haven't made it work
i mean this is tricky business too but
it's tricky
bishop the bishop landing on uh c7
with an h5 potential push is going to
cause some consternation on the g3
square
so so maybe you just go like that rook
a1 bishop c7 immediately
you say where's the road going i assume
it goes back to e2
doesn't go back background i always have
knight f4 though
not right now maybe but at some point
maybe i start with h5 and h5 what do you
what do you do you don't want to play h4
h4 allows actually
no i don't want to play h4 probably i
just
drop back from my king invite you to win
your pawn back bishop takes
g3 f takes g3
well wait you i might take the pawn back
or i might play h4
knight comes to f4 yeah yeah
i changed my mind because i didn't
realize how strong h5 was
maybe bishop c7 is really annoying yeah
when it was on d4 it was lining up
against everybody all right
it's lining up against everybody that
bishop about 83 is the culprit by the
way
it's not doing anything over there just
biting on air
open diagonal yeah yeah and and bishop
on c7 is
i mean just a beast that bishop is
amazing
and let's take a look we're telling
we're being told
that there's a couple of updates in the
netherlands you took with the
f pawn
takes g3 looks like an open fast seems
reasonable really really it goes against
capture towards the center so you could
go f4
and queen c3 look logical to me
uh this recapture is a okay a little
confusing well come on guys that's
that's
really confusing that's really confusing
f file noaa file what
hgf4 is kind of the plan right right
queen to c3 c5f
maybe he thought he was executing c5
anyway and he was going to get
everything on the queen side and so he
wanted an extra file
for his for everything he's going to do
but c5 came
screeching back at him and he
it looks like he's taken on c5 and we'd
say bc5 is forced
is it well knight takes
rook takes e6 looks brutal no i wouldn't
no i i i think you i think you have to
stick with the knight
because b takes c5 there's nothing
specifically wrong with b takes e5 but i
think you're trying to win as maxime
and you want to get this knight into the
game and hope there's a tactic here
but weren't you because my night before
rook a2 and some chances what
why it go down upon you i mean you say
hope having
dude yeah well
indeed let him tell us
where's your tactic i'm hoping for
something but let me find it
oh i thought you had something in mind
it was a good shot yeah rook fate but
there's a rook f1
rook f100 a1 is too much right now even
i don't believe in that
all right
g5 maybe what's yeah f1 queen g5 you
know
you know what's running i'm gonna try
okay all right there you go so you're
hanging
the d6 knight that's fine because of
what because queen e3 picks up your
knight that was the only reason
okay that's a good reason though i don't
want to see
queen e3 landing on my doorstep now you
got it
okay he's got rook a2 ideas he's not
giving it up yet he's okay rook eight
well knight f3 is coming with tempo
will be at tempo all right but the queen
on c3 allows knight a4 right
gedubski you're right knight a4 is a
nasty nasty fork okay that wasn't part
of the
you know consolidate program
okay i'm gonna say if i see queen g5
i'm warming up i mean you know you're in
there with a shout
out yeah yeah i still don't really know
[Music]
if my threats are decisive but i have a
threat which is more than i could ask
for
like two minutes of three here rook f3
maybe a strong move let me just take
this guy for just a second let me just
see if i can
just say okay uh but can i
can i throw in the check no i cannot
right no i can if i want to
seriously what yeah i think i can
because because queen e3 check work f2
knight d3 hits both rocks
wow that is
finish the line please queen takes
knight
queen takes knight queen takes queens d6
rook between takes knight
rook takes d7 yeah maybe that's too many
pieces
that's a lot of pieces i got bishop one
at the end so
yeah oh that's very
good but you were but you were on a roll
there 193 really look good
i gotta
that's a much better uh breakdown right
here i could ignite whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
that's sexy right after that
like something is really weird
i i've been winning pieces stopped
counting because pizzas i mean
just throwing it at four it's nice yeah
that's crazy
we're throwing pieces around like i'm
glad they're not ours
this is an insane line it
uh so a controversial moment
uh for our audience as we uh that is to
say maurice and i were just thinking
well b
take c5 not going down upon and jumping
with the knight to b4 is a logic
but alejandro is saying takes takes
let's let's try to
get some real threats going i feel
knockout
knockout style threats with queen g5 and
queen e3
um big moment big moment and by the way
again i just don't like the way uh nepo
has played his last i'm gonna say
five six moves uh he seems like he's
let some of his advantage slip by the
way a game we haven't seen
let's just give a salute to
these two players wang hao and fabiano
uh this was a very quiet sicilian guys
that somehow got completely balanced if
you said this came out of a french
exchange variation i would believe you
and there much we can say about this
position
thank you for showing us this game
yasser
i guess that answered that one why the
video game is much more yes
by the way i was intrigued by your
capture alejandra because those tactics
just look so fierce and i just
turn on the engine to take a look and
take a look at this line the engine says
this is slightly
worse for black based on this idea rook
f8
yep rook to f1
yeah and black actually has the
extraordinary and this is
so okay i'm talking but
nepo just played an insane move we're
gonna have to get back to that let's
just show this variation very quickly
queen to d8
talk about tricky dickey nobody sees
that
rook takes d6 rook takes f a f1
cleaned up that little exchange and you
take back and now queen c7
can you say your rook is going nowhere
what is that that's white has to bail
with rook takes on d7
what that's hard to
absolutely insane guys i i think there's
been a glitch
on the board i can't no no no no no
glitches
john played rook b5 the move played in
the game is rook
i mean rook b6 looks like a move but
rook b5 is that real that's what i was
shocked well what are you guys looking
at uh
i'm sorry uh once again alejandro our
feed right now has
ro is the pawn taking on c5 and rook b5
that's what our favorite is what our
feed is showing right now
exactly that that that's what i'm saying
i don't believe
i think there's been a milestone
something's wrong something's wrong
i can't believe it be five uh
no it's just a terrible no no no knight
c5
rook b6 queen d8 is the game knight
okay then we've got the wrong feed over
there knight c5 or rook v6
queen david8 yes as maurice had said but
he didn't throw in the move rook cafe
ah he didn't throw in the movie cafe i
don't know if it makes a big difference
actually i would prefer to throw in the
move for a cafe but i think it might
because you kind of like to see that
rook on
on d1 being pushed over to f1 but
okay this is the current position holy
spokes
but what a great find there by maximum
this idea of queen d8 where i was so
focused on making threats with queen g5
and stuff like that
you guys just refuted all of them queen
the adrian maneuvering the queen taking
advantage of the dark squares
we got a game in our hands i mean it's a
pawn i'd rather be white but
yeah i wouldn't be worried about that
king all right i would not rather
i would not rather be white i'm gonna
tell you really yeah well first of all
because i don't care about pawns i'm not
like
you know that's like yasser's there yes
sir yes sir would not let me in
the building actually he would in order
to try to indoctrinate me into
my ways but the thing the thing is with
white
the only thing you can say right now
about white's position
very clean thing you can say is that
white is a head
a pawn right because that bishop oh that
bishop on b7
i'm not i'm not okay i'm not really
talking about
black yet can we leave black along for a
second let's not punch
the black be the punching bag just yet
right i'm just talking about the
activity of white's pieces
the knights do not impress the knights
are not impressive
the bishop and knight on d2 are both and
the queen as well
are both busy holding down this pawn the
c4 pawn
later i will attack you with a bishop
make that wake up
the c4 pawn could be something you need
to defend
and your but your work on b6 you know
you're up upon you might be able to do
something but when you look at black's
pieces
suddenly blockading knights what more
could you ask for tag teaming on pawns
that's good as well there's an open file
potential and
queen g5 will return it it's not in the
position at the moment
but it will return and the rook on the a
file
will it go to a3 to stop i don't know
where it'll go i'm making stuff up there
but there is something you can start to
look at in blacksmith
i think if the computer gave this as a
decisive advantage for white
you still take black as a winning
goal exactly exactly if you want to try
to win
you suddenly have a chance to make
something
get the guy uncomfortable i just sacked
a pawn in your face
not the kind of poem where you say oh
i'm just going to refute this this is
over this is done
i just sacked the pawn and said i got
some comp you want to be the challenger
shut everything down i will tell you
maxime loves being black here
nepo loves being black here this is
nepo's kind of chest
geary would say you know what i'm white
in this position
all day you're dead in the water how
dare you sack against me did you see
what i did to dingle wren
when he tried that nonsense nepal is not
the same kind of personality and i would
also say
as he doubles rooks on the b line i
would also say
i'm intrigued because
nepo's clock time is also reflecting
a little little something
right and this competitor is the worst
one nepo could have asked for
in a big time game only one win
six losses more losses than draws
in 11 games did you ever see that at the
high level ever
very rare very very very rare we're
seeing it here
so max seems starting to feel a little
mvl trickery dangerous times right now
and he just played calmly queen c7
well you had to defend the knight and i
totally get the temptation of this
knight on c5 goes somewhere
and queen c5 comes as a decisive threat
right mm-hmm
yeah i mean something like rook a3
knight d3 queen c5 would be
very very suggestive if we could get all
of those moves and
right now white has some issues uh what
are you going to do
yeah i was about to say the the knight
that bothers me the most i'm not
unhappy terribly unhappy about the
knight on d2 they kind of
it balances out with the knight on d6
the the knight
tension that i don't like is the ones
between the c5 and e2 knight
he did play the move knight c3 knight c3
rerouting because i don't think the
knight is going to stay on c3 it's not
doing much i can't play knight b5
because my rook's always hanging
i guess the knight do you think it wants
to trade itself for
no but i would have played knight c1
then right not knight c3
i was trying to go to d3 right that was
a consideration trading for that night
but the problem is
replacing the knight by a night trade
with the queen
captures that's not really that
attractive either but knight c3
that makes for for me i find that move
to be very logical
uh question is would can i get away with
something
some variation like this
what do you think about this i mean we
we looked a moment ago i
really didn't want to see that queen
showing up on
you know my front door step there but uh
should i be trying to trade i don't know
rook a3
what about what i mentioned before the
bishop moving i mean i see your line but
i want to move my bishop off of
b7 put it on a6 yeah i agree with a6
finally this bishop's doing something
why is it working at all
like bishop is working the c pawn just
got
undefended because the knight went to c3
so right queen was guarding it now it's
no longer guarding it
yeah i don't have knight b5 as we
mentioned how do you
i mean am i really threatening this pawn
i don't really know i
i i want to take it but
yeah i'm not sure i have to take with
the bishop i could take with the bishop
i'm not sure you are throughout the
bishop you have rook takes
now bishop d3 like there might be some
well ideas of d6 and knight
i don't know this is a this is a
this is which i think is very logical
not with your kingdom on h1 yes because
there i could take your rook
maybe uh-huh and i have a back rank
issue by the way after knight c3
rook uh excuse me yes
exactly without the move bishop
basically it looks very logical
we've been trying to put it there for a
while well
ever since he put it on e8 i was trying
to get him to go back
you know what i like you know what i
like about this i'm getting more excited
the absence of black pieces they migrate
to dark squares
the two knights on that bishop on g2
that move e4
was hyper solid but taking on fg3 you
guys didn't like i'm warming to the
strategic minuses
big time of that when he took back with
the f pawn and not the h
pawns more control of the dark squares
i'm getting more and more upset about f2
takes g3 that was just like
that just opening up this
door right it's whole game we can see
three it you know you want to play f4 as
your counter play but
we think that the move f2 takes g3 just
well that's maybe a strategy and yeah
the whole position from this from this
moment
queen d8 a fantastic move queen d8
seeing the trap of the rook followed by
he might have thought he was pinning
that knight and all of a sudden queen v8
shows up
and he's not pinning the knight and that
move queen d8 followed by queen c7 and
rook f8 in the full migration
of the black pieces to the dark squares
his next stop is
what to do with the rook on a8 will it
be a3 as you mentioned yes and then
even with the king on a dark square on
g7
full migration to the dark squares it
feels strategically wholesome
a great pawn sack for the dynamism in
the position
it is clear maxim is hunting and trying
to hope that his opponent will feel the
pressure of the moment
and look at i want to say it again the
clock
times nepo is a fast player
very i had an advantage from the
beginning of the game he was
dominating the beginning of the game
right now he's only two minutes ahead
and changed
on the clock on maxim in an unclear
position with 14 moves to go
against an opponent that has had his
number
no other way to put it will he crack
under the pressure i'm saying all that
white's up upon
what does white do right now
what is white's plan here is it does
just not get made it
is it just well i've been thinking about
you know like this knight on e2 it went
to c3 but it's not like it's
wholesome on the c3 square and
yeah 92 to where i mean give me a plan i
i mean if i go back right here i was
actually thinking that well my
king could be you know go king h1 knight
f1 knight f3 put my knight on a decent
square
where i know that it's hitting something
was the song
i mean knight from knight just went from
it was on c3
it went back to e2 he went to c3
let's just say he was on c3 and went to
e2 went back to c3
right he's got the three step going and
now is it going to go back to e2
what's this knight doing it's just
moving around
almost purposeless and all of white's
pieces now you're up a pawn but you're
defending
you take black in this position all day
i think so a compensation type player
and if you're playing for a potential
win
and that bishop the only piece that is
relegated to light squares i'm seeing
a6 for it that's going to be a useful
square
and all white is doing right now is
holding down the forward
matter of fact i'm going to argue this
what if black does nothing and says
would you like a draw
right what does what what is white's
actual sequence of moves give white
three moves what does white do well
again i
i come to this night on c3 and i say i
need it
to perform uh frankly i want it to be on
a better
circuit so
i play knight e
knight d1 to f2 to
g4 i i i need some purposefulness for my
pieces
and by the way i i'm starting to worry
about even ideas like knight a4 and
queen c5 shack
it's weird uh i don't like what nepo has
done
and as we've been mentioning nepo a very
very fast player is taking his time
as he's facing some well challenging
problems knight's e3 didn't like has
great compensation guys and
i don't like this i don't like there's
even there's even a straightforward
attack on the c
pawn right bishop a6 rook c8
hiding that attack you're gonna have to
defend forever
you don't have any pawn breaks you have
no pawn breaks and no easy way to
suggest trades
your bish and by the way don't make any
old trades because your bishop on g2
it ain't exactly a superstar no it's not
you could try to move it around i can't
even find a single square for it on the
board
where would you put other than h3 yeah
exactly you got h3
where so and now what like exactly yeah
it's not where do i
it doesn't have a plan for improvement
let's whoa let's take a
quick look at that game i was about to
say just to drop in and see
how in a neat let's see we've had some
changes when we left it we just saw the
move rook b5
maybe gift meet upon on e5 and
anish said you want it you can have it
and h4 and f3 instead
well very solid approach by cruz
as a niche i feel deflated when i see
moves like h4 and f3 uh f3 is
rock solid it's basically saying look i
i may blunder a fork i may blunder
something but i am keeping my structure
and as long as i keep my structure well
there'll be a weakness over here rook b1
will eventually show up
um well it needs
hard hard work for for for a niche to a
loss a loss loses completely
but does he have to win it
if because he's not if nepo decides
that not if mvl decides that he's ready
to play another
one of those games of his life as we saw
in the sink field cup the last round
you mentioned it on the previous
broadcast uh
that in the last round mvl to win the
sink fill cup to have one of the
greatest results of his career
needed to win against nepo and he played
a gem of a game as white and
won against nepo and that game with the
white pieces but
as we're looking at nepo's this is
yeah there you see it rook b2 a kind of
indication
that well there's no more forward
in the position maybe it's trying to
it's time to look for that knight b5
trade that
start trading some pieces right right
get rid of the blockade maybe if i can
get
knight b5 and even c4 takes b5
which would of course block my rooks on
the b file but in that case
at least the knight on c will have a c4
square so
uh well we knew he needed to do
something
he didn't play knight b5 i'm playing
bishop a6
i just wanted to play playing please
play
and i've completed i'm almost done
completing the the dark
play rook a3 i think you wanna play
rogue f2 even that's saucier
i've completed the migration to the dark
squares
and playing checkers that's right
and now you better watch out i mean
but is it i i hear you uh maurice i i
think that
black is looking at a better position
now than
you know since the start of the game but
still i mean there is this move queen c3
and okay so that's i suggested rook a3
that was i hadn't seen queen f2
i mean rookie i'm sorry rook a3 instead
seems more circumspect guarding
the the squares and maybe i'll play rook
e3
he has to play bishop a6 rook bishop
basics
in that line yes rookie with the threat
of rook
e3 king h1 rook a3 and you can't the key
is that you cannot play
rook to b3 right now i want to play rook
e3
and truly harass you oh wait oh knight
d3
i mean what is that knight d3 is a
threat
this sucks why are you kidding me look
at that bishop on g2
i don't want to look at that position g2
i'm terrible
it grabbed space a long time ago and but
by taking with the f pawn
e4 and the combination of taking with
the f pawn and he's played knight to d1
yeah the move you had suggested earlier
you guys get that night somewhere
full retreat mode for white right now
yeah it it again there's been some
challenges that white's had to
face this rook on b6
it did win a pawn but it was hoping for
something
more than just grabbing the pawn and
retreating
at the time that he played rook b6 there
was a
a pin on the sixth rank and
well mbl dealt with that
and now well again the knight
needs needs a role so okay i'm going to
applaud
this line of play uh by
nepo and say okay i agree i'm in retreat
but i got a pawn and do you have a
killer
move more importantly most importantly
can you
that's what i was going to say can you
find a way to continue the pressure
keep building right and maybe something
like just
rook f6 rook over queen queen c3 bothers
me though your queen c3
is a move i'm worried about well at the
moment
i mean it does allow knight a4 right
yeah well okay um
be careful there's a pawn already in the
pocket so if you like
the thing about it is not so much that i
win the exchange but you go knight a4
queen takes e5 i still have queen c5
intermediate
why would i take immediately yeah don't
don't do that
that that might hurt me but i go queen
c5 check i take away your d4 square i go
rookie eight
and things are not looking very pretty
for this queen that that's
that's a nice little variation like that
that's a visual
that's a nice game okay that's defending
because queen g5 is forced
right and now i can consider to actually
you know take on b2 maybe play queen d4
right who's taking it yeah right that's
a big difference right that exchange
compared to the last one
yeah well played well played great
variation okay
so rook f6 is a thought
yeah rook f6 is uh we're doubling
it very well a7 is sleeping in the
position it's lurking
yeah yeah with some tacticos
hello i don't see any killing blow so
just improve your position right yep
yep that's that's why i'm thinking you
just okay so let's imagine i go
king here let's imagine you go rook f8
and let's
imagine i go rook here so i've got the
business squares covered
by my knights
is your next move maybe queen c3
and queen e3 or maybe maybe and i know
it's a little bit of
a reach but knight e3 knight g4
but okay i'm going to say queen c3 is my
next move
so far i've got all the business squares
covered
it's kind of weird but this rooks they
don't do much
yeah i would like to just stack it like
rook f2 or something but it's too much
right
did did we did we miss play it for black
played yeah maybe this rook doubling is
more tempting than
it is good right because you have no
entry points maybe you need to play rook
c8 and go after the sea pawn
please keep an eye on no no i don't want
to do that
i don't you're trying to say i guess the
truth is to win the game as opposed to
getting back to equality
right i get it anything too critical i
mean i think mbl's
but rook a3 b prior to play bishop a6
made more sense to me i like i like that
knight
okay three knight b5 was an issue right
hold on hold on we're not thinking we're
not thinking the right way
the knight was on c3
yeah you dig with the pawn right because
here i have knight c4 next move
knight c4 next move i don't know
yeah i i can't because we go yeah the
knight just left
c3 hold on
bishop okay rook f8 rook b2
bishop went to a6 knight went to d1 this
is the current position um maurice uh
sorry what would you like
no i wanted the tactic i wanted i was
ghosting because the bishop was on
p7 so i want to play knight a4 but the
bishop just went to a6
exactly right right
it feels we need to improve our position
i just don't know what i want to improve
here
exactly uh the rook went to f8 with
purpose
and we understood that
we were thinking it could go to double
uh can we take a
move out of about out of maybe
on issues playbook something like
king side that i see with the move h5 in
particular
is that i weaken g5 and if white plays
h4 they weaken g4 but i always have a
light squared bishop and you're not
getting anything to g4 anytime soon
so did i really gain anything with h5h4
or on the contrary did white gain
something
well it's all based on yeah i mean a
moment ago
i would have been very reluctant to play
h2h4 if the right had landed but
you're right the inclusion of these two
moves may be
favorable for white because hold on hold
your horses hold your horses now my
knight
can go to you asked and maybe the knight
can go
to the g4 square with a knight e8
maneuver
you know what i do if i were black here
and again i i'm talking about
bridge burning and the whole
enchilada yeah oh
no that's the oh now i'm posting up
oh my goodness and three pawns down
but going all in going all in
all in all in i was thinking more like
steinitz
knight e8 knight f6 type chest the
knight gets off of d6
and goes to find some activity on this
square and then put my queen on a7 and
ask you what the heck you're doing
but that that's the positional route
i like you're playing like tom
[Laughter]
some institute down the street because
i'm going to say yes
ashley mbl's move invaded my mind
i would have never thought of uh oh
i thought of it momentarily but i didn't
think it made any sense at all to try to
win with
offering trades that's astonishing eight
what if i trade everything and go queen
b2
wow that's just i thought that is i
thought
that's a sigh of relief black was
looking for
compensation but after queen b2
hey guys i'll take white that's
astonishing which has happened
i'm upon up in an ending i'm not saying
i'm going to win the same game all the
time but
no this is
this is a dream
you have to take right no i guess you
can go or queen e8
no queen eight queen b6 is horrible
oh that's just embarrassing i mean you
just left your whole
uh minor pieces on what else can you
play
this is i don't understand what being
what this is this is
unbelievable what just happened mvl just
played rook to b8
that's unbelievable that that
i'm gonna say that's not really the move
is it really the move um
please tell me it's not really the move
uh that's unbelievable
maybe it was wrong c8 yes
rook b8 i refuse to believe mvl played
rook b8
oh i refuse that's that move
is that there's no tactical trick not
taking that rook back so you have to
take the rook back
right there's no tactical trick i refuse
to believe rook beat is the move
somebody tell me that's not you take
take take and go queen b2
right yep right instantly pretty
straightforward
instantly gift me the pawn the only move
here is knight
db7 what david
b7 so i don't want to trade fan
only way like that's the engine move and
id b7 is the engine move
no no it's my move it's my movie he's
saying
i can't trade queens you can't you trade
queens you have no
if you want to draw a trade queen but
knight dv7 i don't understand knight db7
queen v6
when are you going to move again i know
i can move my that queen is
like my queen at least my queen is free
i mean i i don't know where it's going
but congratulations
but uh you're you're i'm not i i'm not a
big fan of right now
and he's trading and he is trading on b
this is unbelievable the move rook b8 is
simply on but
it's like double question mark in this
situation
yeah i would have definitely and he's
gone for it i can't believe it it
actually was played
jan has now played queen b2 this is a
this is a travesty
this was it if he is super confused
i am so confused if if i if i'm thinking
i'm black
and you know like draw just kills my
tournament forget about it it's it's
it's do or die it i i go all
in i'm playing h5 i'm not trading pieces
while i'm upon no down i mean it's the
same for max seem to lose or to draw
this is the exact same right right yes
so
h5 yeah i mean okay i maybe go
i i might go down in a blaze of glory
but it's going to be a blaze of glory
i'm going to take
i am going to make my opponent sweat
things out after rook f4 i promise you
this has some serious play but rook b8
is
is is almost like giving it up it's just
absolute capitulation
yeah you may be hold but when do you
ever win this
you never win never ever never
ever ever win that's just sure you've
got a great blockade you put your king
on
f6 although king the e3 this is horrible
that was strange strange no i mean
no and anish gary is probably wondering
what
dude i was hoping that you were going to
give him
a scare let me check out anish gary what
just happened
because we have after the move
after the move well well f3
we saw knight d7 shades of anish versus
uh fabi by the way as anish likes
planting
knights on the e4 so he's going into
that end game
he took on b2 you mean and
max yeah maxime like i i i just can't
get this out of my head like what
what would attract you what on earth
would attract you to this ending i
really don't think
you lose it all the time
[Laughter]
hey guys i got good news you know like
like when i get into depending upon down
i don't always
lose what by the way
by the way white isn't white
sort of kind of threatening to bring his
king to b4 what do you mean sort of kind
of you go
why not it just wins i get my kingdom
before i just win
i mean you resign this is i
i'm as a commentator yes as a fan
as a player just as a competitor
i am stunned mortified
that he actually played this way there
is just
like there's no way in that position we
go back and you say which move do you
play that you play rook to b8
trade off all the rooks give him queen
b2 trade off queens be down upon
in an end game where yeah your knights
are blockading and you hope you save the
position
but you need to win the game it's your
only chance and you have
the worst part is you actually have
chances right right
is in there dark square control this is
mvl's type of position
like for him to actually do that it's
stunning like uh really we were looking
at
ideas of uh excuse me i just want to
show
so show the folks ideas that we were
kind of looking at i mean this is just
one indication of of how things could go
horribly wrong for white provided that
there were queens still on the board
that there were
i mean we saw not necessarily ghosts of
threats but yeah there were some real
threats get your knight to d3
and the fact that that uh
well the p says white's pieces have been
coming backwards the rook came back to
b2
the knight went from e2 to d1
and it was probably heading to e3 and
then suddenly
mbl gave nepo a
clear path of what he needed to do trade
everything off the board and
i think maurice i'm literally physically
in pain
that the king is going to come to before
i'm it's hard for me right now
it really is it's not i don't have a dog
in the fight of course we want it to be
an interesting tournament
if mvl would won it would have been
interesting he was far from winning
far from right of course it was
interesting it was going to be
interesting as as a viewer as a fan as a
commentator
as a player to watch how a great player
tries to make something
of a position that
there was some compensation but glory to
potentially be had by putting
pressure on his opponent giving his
opponent a scare giving him some stress
he just played rook back to b2 knight to
d1 he's thinking oh man i let this
go i had this dominant position and i
let it go and now the guy's trying to
hunt me down
and then rook v8 appears on the board
and if you're white your nipple you go
wow thank you i can trade everything off
and play queen b2
uh i can never lose that what's going on
and you win sometimes it's not even it's
not even that perhaps the tournament
dictated that nepal must win and he
can't really go for it because you don't
make progress
you have chances you have real chances
to win this for white
of course you're gone up why not and i
liked your idea of just
b-lining uh a root
with your king to the b4 square once
your king gets to b4
then you can start figuring out how
you're going to make a night trade
to make further progress and three
knight d3
you lift the blockade on c5 right right
right right play bishop to f1
maybe bishop will poke its head out to
the h3 diagonal
as soon as the pawn gets to d6 as soon
as the pawn gets to d6
poking the bishop o here to stop it
you know a knight d7 yeah yeah yeah you
start to warm up to the task but it's a
two result
game this just always literally
if there was if there was a teddy bear
that had the word
draw on it maxim any idea
there's there's a there's one that says
win and one that says draw
and maxim said give me the draw one
that's i'm
embracing the idea of the draw burn the
other one
i want the draw let's see if i can even
get it
by the way who says he's going to get it
we're all agreeing
you may not get it at all sir i don't
know what you think you're doing
all right but let's take a look we're
maxine
the draw that's just like unbelievable i
just can't explain it
uh we're all we're all we're all
confused uh by the way it looks to
my eyes that uh well
sasha sasha is definitely the one
pushing
here um obviously
all we need to do is get to the d5
square with the knight
we there's just one small possibility of
black playing f5 but
don't i just love white's position here
well what was the problem with just
playing rook
db5 sorry bd5 immediately
no i'm just wondering how you defend
this pawn
no no no problem at all i was wanting to
put the knight there but rook
rook boy d5 yeah
i mean i go queen d2 next move see grace
rick starts with knight e3 which i like
it's a very flexible move
you don't know if you want the knight on
d5 you want the rook on d5 it's always
useful to make this
moves that you know the knight has to go
to e3 make that move first
the more professional approach uh the
only
the only thing i have to do right now
yeah the only thing i have to say to
that
in knight e3 is f5 not the move that i'm
i'm happy with
i'm just thinking you know dang
this is not this is really we like
i've got really active pieces i do like
your move rook b5 i've got really active
rook
this rook is passive this knight once it
gets to the d5 square
it's huge so he just played knight e3
okay
uh advantage gracious no question today
i'll win by and the tournament's over i
think you play a five and pray
you don't even calculate it exactly
because what else do you do if you don't
if this doesn't work
exactly and this might not work but if
f5 doesn't work
what is your move yeah i see
i'm seeing the rook slide across the
board with the idea of
f5 so maybe i can do that in a nicer way
so i want to allow this move uh
what can i do this what
what do you guys reckon is i mean rugby
d5 always looks strong
i like queen b2 honestly i didn't see
what was wrong with that nothing is
wrong
and you like the move f4 as well right
f4 looks great i'm taking on b6 i'm
threading f5 i'm throwing rook g5 i'm
threatening knight d5 do i need more
the knight on e3 is tremendous by the
way
97 e7
oh no oh boy the ticket is
an indication right right now to dubai
this was the worst position that that
that uh anisha's had since his first
round lost
this worst position how do you defend
this pawn if i just attack it with queen
b2
exactly please please please do not tell
me it's night c
no no no no knight c8 knight d5 i'm
already signing the score sheets
the strategic domination of these two
pieces
versus those two pieces is overwhelming
so no knight c8 no that looks
terrible like again if i don't wait for
it when you play the move knight e7 when
you put a knight anywhere
as we know anytime you put your knight
on a square
you must know where it's going to end up
right is it the square it's on or some
future square
the knight on e7 it's stopping knight d5
that's what i want to see it actually
it's not totally stopping knight d5 it's
prepared to trade itself off with
anything that lands
if a knight lands on d5 but that's what
you want if you
are white in this position is for the
knight
to make a move where it's got no hope no
future
no nothing meantime all your pieces are
growing
and black has two clear weaknesses on b6
and d6
this i'm going to say it again a draw a
a draw by
a niche right now would be a miracle
right but if he loses
it's over tournament is over
that's it and we do have
certain moves uh strangely enough
uh bishop to f1
i thought that uh white's king was going
to make a b-line
to the b4 square instead he's put his
king on
e3 i don't know i've
i guess i'm
i would have put my bishop on h3 a move
return to go and i would have again
i would have angled for the b4 squares
um okay if
if mvl makes a draw kudos right
kudos really i mean well done i mean
like what
i no i really don't get it i i saw a
strategic howler the other day
that that uh grisha
took on e5 against dingler and and d4
takes e5 followed by knight on e2 to d4
and the chinese player just i mean it
was
it was over it was lights out a
strategic howler for me
rook b8 i don't even consider that a
strategic tower or a tactical howard
it's just a terrible move
uh just like you don't
it's just bad and uh this i i can't
explain it
bishop e2 by the way on the board now
well a strange tournament gentlemen i
mean a strange
twist in a remarkable tournament i want
to say
yeah it's a little deflating isn't it i
mean yeah yeah
we're as as players watching
we we would argue we wanted to
we wanted to see for even for nepo's
sake
not that he needs any help now that he
you know to deserve anything he deserves
the victory in this tournament he's
played
wonderful chess from from beginning to
end
geary played the better second half so
far
geary right now is in deep trouble so
that could be question mark
and it may be that it was nepo who
played the better first half
and the better second half and deserves
a hundred percent
to win this event we're not saying
anything about that
but we did want to see him pick up the
gauntlet
with the pressure of the moment when
maxine
had given it given him a scare
for him to say you know what i can
handle this scare
as well because i'm going to tell you
something
after the move knight to d1 the way the
game has gone so far bishop a6
knight d1 one magnus carlsen
is never gonna play rook b8
never and if he has this situation where
there's momentum going against him
in a world championship match facing off
against the best player on the planet
i will tell you magnus is not putting
the work on b8
he's just not he's like uh-uh he might
play the h5
move as you mentioned yes he'll put a
rook somewhere else
he's not playing rook v8 and defending
some god forsaken ending
that's not going to happen he's going to
start looking and cooking
and seeing what he could do but not rook
b8 so
you want a real test of what the heat's
going to be like in the world
championship match
when a guy sacks a pawn for compensation
this rook b8 was not it
and it's a shame that that mvl decided
to shut things down here
and not play because again let's say he
lost the game guys
who cares like right nobody cares
everybody would have said
the guy went for it he lost the game who
cares that doesn't affect any a few
rating points
affects nothing but if he wins
yeah he had won the tournament he could
actually still withstand a chance with a
victory to win
a million dollars that's the loser's
purse
to going to the championship
championship yeah a million dollars on
the line
and you decide i'm going to trade pieces
off it's so strange
out of all the blunders that we've seen
this tournament this is the strangest
it's not even a blunder it's not yeah
yeah it's just one of those kind of
sometimes you just have a brain freeze
where
you know afterwards somebody asked it
asks you why did you do that and you go
i really don't know i mean just
inconsistent
with how he started this game he started
this game with let's play something
probably not very very very risky
strategically bad let's just get into
one of these positions where there's a
lot of pieces
hopefully we get something out of it
i'll manage from a worse position
and he did a great job too and he did a
great job he got
a worse position he achieved he achieved
the best he was the worst position
yeah yeah but and let's take a look at
what happens
if deadpool what do you mean if we never
win neville wins it's over
let's take a look uh what do we have
here
we're being told uh that
that's magnus next yep
oh look at their uh head to head
that's who who else has a
nobody has a lot like this against
magnus
what are you kidding me four wins six
draws
all day every day that's an amazing
amazing stack it has been a while since
nepal beat carlson
in classical chess right was it from
junior days or what happened
i think 2011 if i can say
in uh sicilian was that
last i think so maybe
that said alejandro it's been never
since magnus beat him twice
yeah that's true so so if you're gonna
say
trickiest opponent from magnus we're
gonna go down the whole list
toughest the top toughest
head to head but trickiest opponent
this guy has shown himself to be uh
unorthodox in his style
and kind of you know what he likes to do
against magnus he likes to play
the way mvl played in this game he likes
to mix it up
create some odd looking chances
bizarre looking kind of game play
quickly
confuse the world champion and we've
seen
magnus sometimes get befuddled uh in
in positions against nepo
nepo does have that a little quirky
style sometimes stylistic differences
matter more than strength and
you might be not as strong as somebody
else but you might be the one person
somebody i don't like playing that guy
he does some weird stuff
that i don't understand and i know we
all have players like that
i don't like that every time i play this
guy it's annoying
uh this is what a nepo brings to the
table and i think everybody's going to
bill it as can magnus defeat a player
who has
a massive score against him a pretty
good score against them in the past
guys guys we gotta go to the gyri game
f5
on the board saying look i have to win
choice
but f5 out of all the times that he
could have played f5
why
he's doing it at the worst possible time
moment now of course you can't take with
the knight because
oops that just invites the queen to land
on g5 it means that he has to take with
the pawn
which is strategically lost i mean look
what you've just done to your structure
i mean
oh here i i've got the feeling that
knight
d5 should just uh clinch the game
i don't even want to trade off my knight
for your night i just i'd like to enjoy
this position
a little bit you're enjoying plenty
don't you don't you look like that
[Music]
this is this is this is not worth this
is over a geary loss
is a a geary actually a geary loss
the only thing you would say is nepal
wouldn't nepo doesn't clinch it with a
geary loss
so long as he does unless unless
and because if nvl wins nepal would have
to collapse again
and mvr would have to win again so there
is a mathematical chance
but seriously where we are right now
given the position that nepo has
in his game against maxine aguirre loss
is that that's the end of this case
wait queen takes d6 by the way who was
defending that pawn right yeah
i didn't even realize the pawn was
hanging it's so
bad it's resigning oh oh my god he's
losing b6
dude queen takes d6
knight c6 has been played by the way six
the night used to be on c6 so we're
seeing a little hippity hop
this night and uh that's all he's
he's in a what i would say he's in a
daze right now is geary
he's stunned yeah he can't believe it he
never got a chance
he never woke up in this game he never
woke up he just
this was really bad but but guys i mean
queen d6 knight c6
the guy kicks a little bit but he takes
f5
i don't know i i mean i'm looking at he
takes f5 and there's just no kicking
it's like queen d6 is kicking what
what's your definition of kicking okay
26 knight c6 is
well okay i'm threatening to take i will
make a simple
question please can i maybe it's not so
simple now that i see it but can i take
on f5
okay i made you somehow probably
i have the feeling i do right if you if
you
yeah yeah yeah that's it
i mean that clears the cops the only
thing
i was reluctant about was queen takes e3
but i'm not even reluctant
once i see check and that this knight is
hanging as well
i still have a little bit of work to do
because the rook's hacking but i think
between g6
i guess you have to go to the fade f6 is
what i wanted to play
and rook okay maybe this is not
i'm sorry rook h5 rick h5 queen e2
king h3 and queen
e6 g4 i cry yep i mean all right
yeah i believe myself
nicely done aleandro together together
we could you could all do it but yeah
okay
uh in that case yeah queen d6 and ef5
kills uh i just thought ef5 and i just
didn't see
i mean again i guess it's just stylistic
but
i think that this would have been yeah i
think that's just
would have continued after he sees this
because the knight comes to f4
the rook goes to d it's enough it's
enough no it
reminds us yes it reminds us and
everybody should note
there used to be a time when players
would say
best move play the best move play the
best move yeah
that was what we grew up with yeah this
is one
significant change because of engines
that we've seen more and more that they
can just be moves that are
a difference between 6.8 and
4.3 who cares what the best move is
4.3 is good enough for me
6.8 might require you to realize that
there's a queen sack
at the end of it that you had better
notice or else your 6.8
has just turned into a triple zeros or
even a loss
while the 4.3 is lights out no
calculation
nothing to look at it's over and in fact
one of the ways that
cheat detection technology works is when
a player
plays a line that is the more the 6.8
variation
right which requires some kind of
spectacular
reverse moves followed by the queen sack
with a zigzag maneuver
and then a zugswang at the end i mean
like
what is that just happened and that was
what the player played in like five
seconds that was their move
and you go check his pockets boss chair
and effect please
when the variation that existed was
trade off the queens
you're threatening to take another one
the person's gonna resign
right now all right and queen d6
yeah you could have you right yeah as
you could have done the f5 catcher of
course
brishek said i could just take on d6 and
take one f5 and he can resign
and he's done it ef on the board
rushing and i will point out by the way
chris chuck this is a minor point but a
good point
indeed because it will be mentioned in
the russian newspapers
i'm just going to predict it now for
grishtook
a russian to take down the main rival
of nepo a fellow russian
knocking him out people say ah did a
good favor his teammate
his olympic teammate he's maybe through
that is through but
you found druke holy
new best friends for you what you got to
do you do what you got to do
i'm going to take care of this guy for
you okay i'm going to knock him out
and you just just hold down the fort
you're making me chia
it's cool it's good draw is no problem
because i'll get it done on the other
board
and everybody will say bravo
getting the job done so big time win and
in a way where we
we did not suspect anish would have this
kind of horrible i mean
just absolute collapse in a critical
game for him
uh he's got to just be completely
frustrated you want to
try to win with black wow but you want
to at least be
able to try to win with black and
grishard made
no such thing happen in fact gary
didn't even play risky chess to get this
position
maxine played risky chess to get a
potential position
geary played solidly and got nothing and
got worse than nothing now
and now he's about to lose well after uh
yesterday where anish played such a
the day before where he played such a
marvelous game against
fabiano you just go wow the guy's a
chess genius and then today
forcibly reminds me of my favorite quote
by this juanathondanand when asked by an
indian journalist what was it like what
is it like
to be the world chess champion on niche
famously
anon famously responded well every day i
feel like a sportsman
some days i feel like a scientist other
days i feel like an
artist and some days i feel like an
idiot
[Laughter]
yesterday an anish played
fantastic i mean just a marvelous
marvelous
game almost a flawless game if you will
and then today he feels like an idiot i
mean he's just not
it's not been his day by the way we do
have g
takes f5 oh
[Music]
uh whatever you want to do you could do
this yeah
this is done this is multiple best moves
once again
uh multiple choices which one do you
feel like which fits your style the best
it's on you because you're about to be
up two pawns
the other part the other player has zero
compensation
there will be no attacking chances it's
just what
just keep my styles what fits my
particular style best would be
and since is doing what i expected him
to do
the moment you see how clear geary's
position
is he has offered or started
a repetition very smart why not
why win this game you're up upon why
try to even break through don't break
through what's black going to do
right these nights are perfect yeah
it looks like a million dollars minimum
in his bank account
nepo can count it's a 2 million
euro purse euro purse
800 000 euros going to the winner last
time i checked
the currency exchange it was something
like 950
000 for the loser of the dubai match
right amazing amazing
amazing accomplishment for nepo
highlight of his career
no question about it queen takes e6
what can i say i that's that's the
cleanest
in my way of thinking and knight takes
f5
uh god you know some days
you you just feel like you shouldn't
have gotten out of bed
for a niche it's tragic because by the
way
he was putting together at just a
fantastic sorry
candidates over nepo has drawn
maxine vasher lagrave which means
that as soon as anushkiri resigns and we
expect that
any moment we have officially
we will have officially a challenger to
magnus carlson
as it will be the russian jane pomnyacci
that plays
in dubai against the world champion for
all the marbles
no matter what happens in this game
uh yeah it's over and i mean this is too
far gone
no i should say no matter what happens
tomorrow is what i really know
no matter what happens tomorrow that's
right this game is is toast
uh we would we would need to see him get
fancy like
rook takes e5 right now
probably
maybe that bad maybe even that but no
you don't want to do that
but what i mean there's just no
wait isn't isn't rook to
e1 here maurice stop the clock let it go
it's done you can't choose any move it
doesn't
matter d6 rookie once i want to play
my d4
we always joke in the open tournaments
you know
like the moment you know you're you're
the guy losing it just feels like
everybody in the tournament is coming
over to look at your game and going
hmm can he play rookie one i don't know
maybe he could play rook d6
i don't know maybe he's five if you hear
all of these whispers get the hell out
of here
the worst part is even if chris chu
draws the game
uh-oh somehow by some miracle anish
figures out how to draw
the tournament's still over isn't it oh
no no no no in that case
in that case upset the apple car with a
win against girl like all right
that is true no it does need a victory
to clinch it but this
the victory is a foregone conclusion at
this point
he's played rook to d6 challenging
a so-called active piece
uh yeah if anish didn't need a draw to
keep
his chances afloat he would have
resigned in a normal tournament
he's down two pawns he's gonna be uh
down a third
soon no counter play to speak of
yeah he would have resigned he would
have definitely resigned this was
just uh face plan
absolutely not what the doctor and the
thing is he had such a great tournament
so it's
yeah yeah that's what i wanted to say
but he's by the way he's still
having a great tournament of course wow
he's got three wins out of three wins
and one loss in six games
that's a man who showed up to try to win
the whole thing
right if you go three wins one loss in
in in in two draws that's a guy who's
swinging
unfortunately it wasn't enough he was a
point behind
the leader coming into this event
i mean look at this line score so far
and especially
beginning in round eight draw wind draw
win
win a loss eh give him some more games
he might win some more
that's a great brilliant line score and
you add another loss to that
does not diminish his accomplishment but
second place
is not enough it's the candidates the
challengers
all that counts and by the way i said
a million dollar prize fund a billion
dollars guaranteed
it is a million because 950k
for the losers money in uh
in dubai but he also wins a chunk of
change did you figure out how much it
was alejandro
100 so he wins another 100k to start
this event so this is his 100k plus his
950. so it's over a million guaranteed
this draw he makes and this win by by
richard
it's a million dollars plus that he's
taking home
guaranteed today that's
that's nice
good weight a nice weight as uh it's
just
an amazing amazing day for janna palm
that you're one he'll never forget
by the way you know we've all played
spoilers uh of
the role of a spoiler today i just i
gotta give
sasha a hat tip i mean he hasn't had a
great tournament but what we saw today
was my goodness a brilliant performance
i mean he'll look at this game and he
said where have you been
why didn't i play like that for the rest
of the tournament that was great i mean
i played really well sasha will be
saying to himself
i mean he he really did he played a
great game today
i think anish is just trying to see is
there a blunder it's time control
it's time that's why he's moved 35
and he's somehow hoping that there's
some way
remember petrossian famously left his
queen hanging i think it was against
braunstein
right breinstein played the move knight
f5 attacking a queen on d6
and petrossian famously left the queen
sitting on d6 and let bronstein play
knight takes d6 and he went oops
yeah it was one of those backward
looking moves what did i just do
well knight c6 is one of those moves
maybe he'll let me take on d4
hope he doesn't see it somehow he saw it
he played the move rook d2 which is
honestly not the most aggressive move
but
no i was about to say i i was thinking
more
much more aggressive uh knight h6
because
you got a situation here where i mean
and
i'm just playing it very badly by the
way very badly
uh i'll take i'll take this knight off
the board and that h5
pawn is falling and i thought knight h6
check was really strong uh
rook d2 okay it doesn't matter of course
it doesn't matter but
at these moments you kind of want to be
precise two minutes
two and a half minutes more or less for
sasha
he's clean in these moments you want to
be precise
yes in these moments you just want to
get the time control yeah yeah exactly
40. make move 40 and right and say okay
we're going to be on this one for
another hour do you want me to show you
my technique
no no no
go away i don't want you i don't want to
see
nothing and i just played rook d-8
oh what a sad move to play is this
i don't understand what's wrong with
trading and taking on b6 is there is
that amazing i mean where is there was
no way to hold the kings
everything that you moved hung upon so
you can't blame him for hanging upon
okay guys this is bad this is bad okay
let's just go
back to a check in on
let's get some that it sure did
uh somehow i think fabi made a little
bit out of nothing
and by the way wang how when he slipped
and he lost that game to
nepo i was thinking to myself how did he
lose that game he'll be kicking himself
forever
how did i lose that game well something
similar could be said about
this game i mean
did you see how dead this opening was it
was yeah it was
bad let's get back to the other game
please i i would love i would
we can we're going to be at this one for
a while let's get the moment of
resignation
when it becomes official that
nepo is indeed the challenger we're just
waiting for anisha so
it's a resignation to watch basically
after rook to d5
it's going to be a moment when we can
announce it
that it happened that it actually has
occurred we have history in the making a
new challenger
to the title magnus now and his team
they probably predicted it already but
they're all now
all hands on deck we've got
a star russian player to try to take
down
another one karjatkin was his first
and now here comes nepo and you can bet
all of
the russian teams will be ganging up to
try to figure out how to take down
magnus
um by the way guys help me out here uh i
have it in my mind
maybe it was just when magnus was still
not quite yet the challenger didn't he
have
nepo as his trainer no he was he was uh
already challenger we do have a couple
of moves guys rook took on d5
and c takes d5 it's a night end game
two pawns to the good
yeah which we consider more than enough
but you know what there is a little b5
no no no stop stop no i'm not going to
let you finish that
i'm not going to let you finish oh but
there is
no b5 before
[Music]
95 i mean come on man 95
on the board that was move 39. will he
let you play a4
right now or does he even care i mean i
mean b4 that is b5 that is
i was thinking white could just play a4
and
now the b6 pawn you'll have to protect
for the rest of your life as 97 knight
c8 would be a threat
and you'd be tied down and right just
but
white just needs one more and knight d6
looks like a great move right now too
threatening f4 okay i know it's bad i
mean my c6 immediately is the most
clinical
yeah knight d6 looks looks absolutely
stunning
knight c4 knight and it's on the board
knight d6 he's made the 40th move
is it right now that he resigns because
now i mean it's definitive that the
position is busted
but he's made move 40 and i would
suspect
this is the moment aneesh can
justifiably say
i kept making moves because
but now after this move there's no
there's no because there's just no
because a4 is threatened
to freeze your pawn and then you know
he's ready to play
you can't even play king f8 a4 and you
can't move your king to e7 because of
knight c8
so you can't approach the knight you
literally just can't and you can't move
your knight
actually you have to move something
what are you gonna do king f8 a4 and
you're absolutely frozen
it's nothing to do you don't even have
to play a4 i can just bring the king
i mean a4 is nice because it solidifies
the queen side but you don't need it
right
but no this is yeah two pawns uh for
sure
by the way uh if you don't mind i i know
it's
not uh for a million dollars
and it's you know just trying to get out
of the basement
it's for five thousand dollars really
how that's the difference
oh oh hey listen you know i mean i
fought a lot of
open events
and i remember quite a number yeah
quite a number of open tournaments had
like that as a as a first prize
what do we got here one two three four
he did play king f8 by the way
in the game decided to just keep going
a little bit longer only hope is some
kind of ridiculous
mind freeze on gristrok's part to make
uh to make some blunder that allows a
draw
somehow some way inside why resign now
i could after whatever happens i'm still
going home anyway it doesn't matter
so let's keep making some moves so there
we go but
else to do richard now with all the time
in the world
grisha could win this in less than a
minute if you gave him a minute on the
clock
of course win this game unfortunately he
has an hour so we have to sit here
follow christian's rule of if i have
time i play
i play let's go i think not i play i
think
thing yeah i think i think
well we might as well take a look at the
other games in that case you were
mentioning the alexenko game
where it's upon down but this pawn is
somehow
exactly how the pawn got all the way
over here
uh seriously there's no pawn on h5 i
expected that pawn to reach h5
a long time ago right yeah when the king
was
if you don't mind by the way let's go
back to that moment when
he did have uh he had sacrificed the
pawn we were looking at something like
rook a1 e1 the lazy man's move
and allowing bishop c7 and h5h4
we started to think that dingleran was
getting something
somewhere uh bishop takes d5 was
carol's move and he traded
off some material played c4
and he said okay i'm relatively safe
my king is
you haven't done too much
well first indications to my mind is
that kirill's
playing a fine game oh did i want to
draw
didn't want to draw said look this is my
maiden voyage
i don't know how many candidates i'm
going to play in but let me get
as much experience as i can and ding
said
uh okay let's play well
it's a bit scary to play a move for
white though because you could
defend i think with queenie one right
but let me take a pawn
yeah but then i go rugby on i understand
and you're gonna go h4 and i'm gonna go
to uh stop you from playing h5
h4 he just
queen h6 queen
h6
um that's queen eight one is
uh quincy one is yummy yeah
very much so i i thought i was
wow okay queenie one maybe because of
this variation actually
very good i i
you know i i'm a card-carrying member of
uh the pawn grubbers of society so if i
didn't look at bishop a3
first you know i might lose my
chairmanship queenie won okay
stopping rook uh check
and that variation i guess rook d8 still
know
looks like a very good move we might see
a repetition after all
with queenie two and rook v8
okay fair enough let's just jump to the
fabi game fabi
i mean every time i look at it i just
feel like he's making incremental
progress
but how significant is it sorry mary's
yes
i'm sorry he yeah it's good moves i just
saw two moves get played in the other
game
in the main game versus anish
king f2 king e7
drawing attempt what is king e7
yeah he's trying to say that knight
would have to go all the way back to a4
and then i have knight c4 or something i
don't know
you didn't play knight interesting
taking the pawn he just backed up
controlling everything on the king on
the queen side
your king can never approach i love the
geometry of this
the knight in the pawn could never
approach
and what do you i mean he's still making
moves but now the king
the white king will will appear on one
of three squares
in the middle uh d4 e4
or even f4 depending on what the black
knight does
and then g4 will happen and i'm looking
like a genius
i mean i could beat anybody
[Laughter]
f5 stopping the king from going to one
of the
top two squares uh
no not allowing g4 either but grishik
said just step back get out of there i'm
playing king e4 in the next move
after you step your king backwards and
when you see sasha speeding up like this
you know
i'm going to make you resign now i i'll
embarrass you king back to f6
king to e4 now yeah kanye 4 looks
would just be what do you plan to do
and king 4 on the board now you've got
to move your knight 98
check is a threat winning the night or
at least trading off nights
and where where do you put your knight
d7
uh it's been it's just been
so horrible i mean we've all been in
anisha's
shoes we just we just know uh
the loss is inevitable there's nothing
we can do but i'm sure he's just
you know going through the game you know
mentally like where
did i mess it up where did i blunder
and it's that feeling that you know it's
over the tournament's over
it really it's a hard to play tomorrow
yeah it's so impactful uh king d4 by the
way is not
bad i mean take take your choice of
victories but
yeah that's just it's like you're gonna
push these puppies at some point just go
g5 go goku
push him baby yeah g4
what about knight c4 okay again
let's stop guys he's dead
the vultures
you know what i like about knight c4
what do you like about knight
although there's what not to like about
everything the point is
now after knight c4 knight c5 check
yeah the move king to e3
is one of those moves where you look at
uh
the position you say my your knight
can't attack
my pawn on a3 or my king on e3 in as
so the king is in the perfect spot the
pawn is in the perfect spot
and in the meantime look at my knight
just like my knights in the perfect spot
you can't script it any better so yes
there are many ways to skin a cat here
it wouldn't be stylistic indeed
uh yeah anyway
one of the things that i've always noted
about
you know grand masters not only do they
play chess really really well but
they're sadists
that took a leap right i would like to
play
king to d for stopping 195.
something i alejandro your turn
ah it's terrible okay it is bad
king d4 played actually oh
king d4 stopping 95 because of the check
stop being knight c5 because of checks
so i dominate the knight
later i could play knight to c4 your
turn
oh boy oh boy g4 is on tap by the way
finally before so that's i think
alejandro that was alejandro's
yeah we we we were resisting
that move enough enough of them playing
around
we know you're a sadist and we know you
like pawns
yeah we also know one of your most
famous
words that i get quoted on my twitch
stream all the time
when i say i push the past pawns and
then your face shows up
somewhere in an email and the words push
a baby
right behind it so well g4 is
is coming
[Music]
we're being told that gristrack has
stepped away from the board
gary he's not thinking he just played a
move so i assume that king e7
kidney says you get some tea you get a
cracker enjoy your position
what do you mean you don't even get a
biscuit for this you just
they revoke your player's pass it's like
it's going to be a bad day okay very
very very bad
uh ding lauren you did play rogue with
the aid
it does seem that queenie to rook b8
might still be some kind of repetition
right it does feel like black ass enough
for the pawn right
oh yeah yeah um it's that knight on g3
and that rook on f3
yeah give me some of your thoughts on
carol carol as we know was invited as a
wild card the organizers
uh nominated him carol played really
outstanding
in the fide open nearly qualified
directly himself
uh what's your take overall uh
um in my opinion yeah he showed
that he can hang in certain positions he
showed
a pretty good understanding in many
but it always felt that he was on the
back foot like you would expect from a
player of his caliber his only win
against grissrook
uh and the only time that he was
pressing besides that i think was
against nepamiachi
in the first half in that french where
he did have a
win that was quite hidden uh it wasn't
able to find it
but the losses were
too disastrous in my opinion like it's
his game against nepo
was it this real disaster yeah in a
complete disaster right
was that he lose to recently he lost to
he lost to favi a position where okay
you lose to favi sometimes
with the black pieces in a car con that
tends to happen but against maxine
zero understanding right like move
savage that was also very bad
very bad like nepo he just never got
into
that game at all yeah so i i think he
did
fine uh he didn't get squash he didn't
lose every game
but it really highlighted that players
reaching 2800 are so much more complete
them players that are 2700 flat you know
they know
every opening they know every idea and
you could see that kirill got caught
in a couple of ideas where he just
didn't know what he was doing
and he lost a little too easily for
for a tournament of this level mm-hmm
yeah that said everything depends on how
a young player reacts to losses
and your chance to play in one of the
most important
events exactly our game exactly fight
the toughest of the tough excluding one
magnus carlsen
when players really really wanted to
beat you
and you are the weakest player in the
field the lowest rated that's
no question about it i think he really
showed heart yeah
i think there's a lot of room for
improvement but he's a young player
right young player so right give him
four years more seasoning yeah give him
four years
he's tasted what it's like to be
in the real hot blooded mix
i think he could come out of this super
motivated he should come out of this
issue
motivated to do better uh even someone i
would say
anish who's 26 now not as young as he
used to be
but anisha's been showing a surge
in strength and ability
26 years old give on these two more
candidates
and these can say okay i didn't get
there this time
but i'm highly motivated i was really
really close
i'm highly motivated so it's just all
your attitude
as you go in and how you play uh so
i think you'll learn from this and
you'll come back stronger
by the way uh queen c3 no
repetitions for you i'll defend the pawn
on d3
and i will definitely i really
really like that about alex senko he's
the lowest rated player in the field and
there's been moments where
the higher rated player says let's make
i'll draw let's
just make peace yeah i don't think was
like nope i'm here to learn i'm here to
play chess
beautiful all right beautiful attitude i
think that's what he needs to do
so there's a lot of improve uh for
alexenko to say
he is one of the candidates but he's
gotten a taste
he knows what he needs to do now and he
can go back home and say
all right let's fix it and let's try to
qualify for the next high cool
by the way there's a lot of fixing
needed let's not make it seem like
i'm just gonna yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah a lot of fixing needed
and he's got to deal with other young
monsters on their way
one ali reza farouja comes to mind
it's not like yeah who's already
basically there as well he's number 12
in the world so he's if he wants to be
of
uh the generation of young players he's
he's older than ferruja by by
four by four or five years and sometimes
we underestimate how hard it is to get
into the candidates you say you're top
ten you're in the candidate
excuse me that's not how it works you
have to qualify
and there are some huge names that are
not here it's not because
they didn't like them or they didn't got
invited no they didn't qualify that's
what happened at the end of the day
we're talking about amazing names like
wesley seoul like sergey karjakin
they just didn't make the tournament and
they tried so
there's a lot of fighting to be done
just to get to the stage
uh can carroll do it again he did show
amazing performance there as you
mentioned in defeated grand swiss
and isle of man same as wang hao uh
but can he keep it up so many players
they say
i want i want to bite for the next one
you know you can already kind of say
uh some some players will be seen in the
next candidates for example either
nepomiaccio or carlson will be at the
next candidates
we know that one for sure uh fabi has a
massive rating it's hard to see him
dropping that much rating in the next
couple of years that he wouldn't really
be there
but for the others we know it's a
grueling process
totally yeah when i think about players
like our very own jeffrey jean
a marvelous player wonderful player
and really fighting to get into the
world's top 50
and then you know what's coming next
getting in the world's top ten
no guarantees of getting into the
candidates qualifying for the candidates
is just tough that's why it's the
apex of our uh event i'm just
told that fabi is
wow i mean that that's a performance to
bounce back after yesterday after the
previous day
where you know well aneesh has played a
marvelous game but
i'm being told he's winning that he's
his advantage is huge he's just played
the move
bishop e4 and previously uh oh
did he really have to play king h1
that's a terrible fight
no the problem with king h1 is bishop
before you know you don't have queen e1
because if you take the moves back right
if you just put the kings back on g1 and
g7
he could have played bishop before
immediately but it runs into queen e1
and there's a nasty pin you don't if you
take i'll trade the queens i'll take the
bishop thank you very much
and we can have a handshake so so
the immediate bishop e4 would have been
met by
and did fabi say okay well i'll play
king g6 and you're in zuk zong
no i just made a move i think but that
precipitated this lousy move because now
bishop e4 and there's no queen e1 as you
were about to point out
alejandro because in this case i turned
the tables with the check
d6 slate d6 and i assume that you have
to play
bishop c6 because otherwise
yeah we respect the pawn
how do you defend this pun exactly
when you're having to defend the knight
something's dropping
if i go queen a3 to defend both the
knight and the pawn
oops and that bishop is doing a great
job summoning that's just me
hey anish got to play b5 b5 is on the
board
dangerous danger will robinson b5
chances
counter play maybe it could be a b4 and
an a4
maybe not that it does anything it looks
like it does nothing
but he
yes exactly very good for him we would
expect
knight c5 by the way
[Music]
i just wanted to say like a lot of
players when i was a
a junior player when i was learning
chess
uh i heard this blockade this blockade
wow
i mean like the the masters and the
experts
in the seattle area would talk about the
blockading
knight for example here i didn't really
understand
understand it i i really had to become a
strong player to realize
that what the blockading knight does in
this case is it just
kills these two pawns it's like they are
they exist
on the board but they're no longer
relevant
and blockading pieces are really nice in
this case
get rid of the blockading knight knight
to c5 and
the pathway to victory is secured with
this move knight to c5
okay uh wang hao uh
now that i'm being i'm in a reflective
mood
we've talked about carol uh why now
he had moments
yep and it's official giri has resigned
guys it is
that will be going to face magnus
carlsen for the world championship match
well it's still months away and it'll be
a russian back at the top top top level
of chess
you know that they are going to prepare
a heck out of that candidate
against magnus carlsen and his team well
in dubai amazing performance by
napolmiacci
you can see there the head-to-head so
far a difficult opponent traditionally
for magnus
even though magnus has gotten the best
of jan in the rapid and blitz portions
you haven't played as much classical
chess as you would expect
players of this caliber to have faced
each other
i would have thought more contests for
sure but that four wins in six draws
11 games and only lost once i mean
uh wow uh if i was magnus carlson i
would say well
that is probably the stickiest
challenger you could have chosen for him
and well with that result let's take a
quick break as we will return
with the rest of the games as well as of
course our predictions for what will
happen
in the world championship match we can
start speculating
about what's going to be going on there
don't go anywhere we'll be
right back
[Music]
go go
[Music]
that's our show now go play yours at
reasonboat.com
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end
has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess
and is comprised of two unique
non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments
including the us chess championships and
the sinkfield cup
one of the strongest chess tournaments
globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries
led by an expert commentary team of
grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess
with a specific focus on bringing the
benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows
children who play chess exhibit improved
analytical skills
and increased confidence the chess club
is highly engaged with the local
community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club
is the world chess hall of fame this
one-of-a-kind cultural institution
invites visitors to experience chess in
imaginative ways
and is home to the us and world chess
halls of faith
cutting-edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess
art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions
and monthly music in the galleries the
world chess hall of fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries
and a premier gift shop highlight the
culture history
and creativity behind the game come
visit play chess
leave enriched to learn more about the
st louis chess campus
visit stlchestcampus.org
professional golf returns to st louis in
2021 the ascension charity classic
presented by
emerson stars like phil mickelson ernie
else jim furyk and more compete at
norwood hills country club
september 6th through the 12th tickets
clubhouse passes hospitality suites and
proam foursomes are on sale now
all proceeds go to north st louis county
charities visit
ascensioncharityclassic.com
or call 314-938-2828 pga tour golf is
back in the loo
the ascension charity classic
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to round 13 of the
candidates we still have a round
14 tomorrow but the tournament is
essentially
over as you can see there it is
the feeding candidate that has won the
tournament
and he is the challenger to magnus
carlsen for the world championship title
a tournament to be held later this year
in dubai guys a deserved spot there for
yane pogniacci
great chance he has shown he will be a
worthy
challenger to magnus yes he will
and you we've seen it because of their
head-to-head match-ups
uh that he has defeated uh
magnus much more often than the world
champions defeated him
um applause but guys before we
do that applause i just wanted to say uh
fabiano after suffering a real real
massive setback
uh has just won his game a little solace
there maurice
no no no not at all really not
bobby doesn't care he's won he's won
games before in his life
he's defeated players at this level
before that's not what counts
what counts is that he won he won that
game on the same day
that another player did what he did
back three years ago uh which was
to win the candidates and have a chance
to become the champion of the world
that is the only dream that matters
to players of that level you can say
fabi hey
you could win a sinful cup uh i've done
that twice
oh fabi you can you can win tata steel
done that fabi maybe you know they're
big tournaments norway
norway did that bobby what do you want
to do in chess
i want to be the champion of the world
that's the only thing that matters when
you're number two
is to become number one he's done
everything else
he cemented himself as one of the
greatest players of this generation
and it's the chance to play for the
world championship title which he will
not get now
for at least another two years we are
assuming
and that's what's on his mind will he be
one of those one-offs
i got a chance once never got a chance
again
that's not a storyline he wants to hear
about he wants to know that he's trying
to get the title
so he's got this game tommy will win
many more games like it
he can show that he can bounce back
indeed but it is jan napolici
who is the superstar of the moment
he is going to play for all the marbles
he can rest on his laurels for a couple
of weeks
get all the the the interviews out the
way
this the me russian media media will be
all
over him all over him he will be giving
he may not like it because you know jan
is not exactly the guy who wants to be
in front of the camera
and answering questions but he will be
able to do so with a smile on his face
and say hey this is the tournament
that i came to play and we have fabiano
caruana waiting for us
right now welcome fabi from
yekaterinburg thanks that goes
hi fabi thank you i'm actually holding
the laptop
right now holding the laptop let's put
it down we could guess
we could guess you were moving
trying to give us some vertigo fabi your
thoughts on your tournament
uh yeah um i mean it's not great
yesterday was uh was a really bad game
um but to be fair even if i had won that
game i
really wouldn't have had a chance um
to fight for first so so yeah
i mean john was was kind of playing
amazingly the whole event and ran away
with it so
um i guess i mean i didn't do my best
but
but it's a very well deserved win for
him
the game with the game with jan and
maxime did you get a chance to look at
that game and the move rook a b8 which
stunned
us uh playing needing to play for a win
and he played this move rook aba what
were your thoughts at that moment
because we were just shocked
that somebody trying to win would play
such a move
actually i was more amazed that he
managed to make it so far in the game
i thought it was like completely dead
it looked it looked so bad and then it
looked like he had already
coordinated his pieces uh but i didn't
actually see this moment because i was
in my own time pressure so
um i didn't didn't see this moment
can you see our screen now it's not like
black has
so many ideas i guess because white is
playing queen c3 next
um so so maybe he didn't really see
an easy move to play
i don't know i mean i guess you can play
97 but it doesn't look like
like black can seriously play for a win
here
he did play fabi everything came off and
they achieved an ending that only has
two results
and that was why we were so stunned
yeah um i mean to be fair was also a
real long shot for maxine he would
basically have to win two two games on
demand and
other results to go his way so i i mean
i think when he lost that game against
grishouk that was pretty much the end of
his uh chances to win the tournament
bobby you're you have been here before
as a candidate what is going on
in nepo's mind right now like what what
was that feeling the immediate aftermath
when you realize you are the challenger
what is that
exact moment like um
i mean the first well for me was a bit
different because i
i for him it came a lot more smoothly i
think and i had to play
uh over a six-hour game so
my main feeling was just tiredness at
the end of
of that game when i wanted the
candidates but of course there's
an enormous amount of of joy
because it is pretty much the
almost the you know the second last the
last step to the biggest goal for any
chess player
um i mean of course the last step is
still the
most difficult but um but just to have a
chance at that is
is a great feeling
all right tell us a little bit about
today's game it seemed
dull but your head always in the game
and you've you found some chances almost
out of nowhere
um yeah no i i i mean
the opening was really sterile but he
kept moving his rook back and forth
and i mean and his knight back and forth
i
i was just kind of i didn't understand
what he was doing
it looked like he just wanted to wait
and wait for me to repeat moves and make
a draw but
i kind of didn't want to end the game
yet um because it looked like i was
making a bit more progress than he was
and after knight a5 i thought okay can't
really be worse here and
it should be a draw but um
but i thought it'll get concrete and
maybe i'll get some chances and
that's sort of what happened and then i
don't know where exactly it went it
actually got worse for him because i
assume this position is equal
and i thought it was basically equal but
then
yeah maybe after bishop d5 maybe b5 is
not great
or i don't know it kind of slowly
started to slip away
and after bishop g6 i already thought
that i'm a little
a tiny bit better um and then after
bishop four i'm
suddenly winning um the the final move
of
yeah i guess he can he can instead of
king he can play f3 and i think it
shouldn't be a draw
um right f3 is just useful to kind of
keep first of all not to lose the f2
pawn after queen e1 queen f2 and to
also stop any sort of mating attacks
with queen takes h3 and the bishop on
the long diagonal
and after bishop before it's
surprisingly just completely busted i
it's very sudden and kind of a lucky
lucky tactic that i have here
did his resignation surprise you at all
fabi
um i i don't know i mean it's it's such
torture to even
fight continue making moves for white
yeah you play f3 and then i play
queen to e or d3 or e5
um one of these moves
actually i have many moves i wasn't sure
exactly which one i would make but um
but slowly black wins this by first
safeguarding the king
maybe putting the bishop on f7 king on
g7 like stopping perpetual
potential perpetuals
and actually i don't know the winning
plan but i think a5 is also weak so
white
will kind of be stretched then with his
defenses
but yeah he can still fight on that's
true
bobby you're again one of the few people
on the planet who knows the pressure of
playing for a world championship match
and also you're playing playing against
this world champion magnus carlsen
what do you think about the matchup i
actually have two questions
uh what do you think about the match up
nepo versus
magnus given that nepo's score is
in classical chess four wins and only
one loss against magnus
that's the first part and the second
part is in the immediate aftermath now
it's time for the
preparing for the guy what did you have
to do what is it that nepo is going to
have to do as far as bringing
all the resources to bear in order to
make a real run at the time
well yeah now now his preparation will
begin and he should
form a team if he i mean i assume he
might already have one
and beginning training because it is it
is a big difference from normal
tournaments to play a match where you
play the same player
game after game and very often um
the same openings are tried and tested
um
i mean his score against magnus is
remarkable i think he's the only one in
the world
with a score like that against magnus um
it shows that he is
he's ready to to try to win um
i don't think he'll really have much of
an effect on the match
i mean because a lot of these games are
also ancient history
um but it shows that he
is very dangerous even for magnus and
but we kind of know that like jan has
always been an incredibly dangerous
player
incredibly strong and just a bit
unstable and now it seems like
he's become more stable and that's why
he's suddenly
you know winning tournaments and
approaching 2800 and
and while he won this tournament also
his stability was kind of kind of
amazing
um at least in the second half
i kind of felt that he would come under
pressure at some point but it never
really
seemed like he was under noticeable
pressure um his level never really
dropped in this event
so yeah i i mean magnus should be
considered a favor but
i don't think it's it's by a huge margin
and i think it'll be a very tough match
for
uh for him for both of them of course
uh phabby if i could get in a quick
question
obviously this tournament had a one-year
hiatus you saw these two players in the
lead
mbl nepo you spent the entire year
and in round eight you uncorked
this enormous novelty uh
how hard had you worked for this year
and what was your mindset
as you started the second half of this
event
yeah i i mean i knew i had a an uphill
uh a steep hill to climb um
i was a point behind two players which
is which is quite
quite a lot for seven rounds and also
there were a lot of players who were in
the tie with me
um so yeah i considered the first game
against maxime very important
really prepared a lot for that game and
uh
and came with some serious prep um but
that was unfortunately the end of the
good news for me
uh after that gameplay my my level just
wasn't there um some games are okay
but unremarkable and at least one game
was extremely
poor and this was a critical game but
even without this poor game i just
wasn't bringing
wins to the table
i i didn't expect that it would be so
that i would have would have to win so
many games but
as it turned out i would have had to
really uh to really go on a tear of this
half and and it never happened at all
um so yeah i think this this hiatus was
really really important for yon and
i think the reason is that he he had
lost the game against maxime in the
seventh round
um and who knows how to how
it would have turned out if uh if we had
continued from that point because
that's a difficult loss to recover from
but a year break was really
really important for for his recovery
um so yeah this break was
turned out to be very good for him and
he was well prepared he was ready um
for the other players it seemed like
like maxime
unfortunately um came
maybe bearing too much pressure or
something went wrong because he
um he started to lose games and very
important ones
thank you for the that insight yeah i
we we we were thrilled but
let's put it bluntly when you won the
round eight
and we didn't quite put the champagne
you know in the ice bucket but we were
reaching we were reaching there
but thank you for that uh fabi and uh
well all
great success in your future endeavors i
know this was
this is painful because as you're saying
i mean it's
it's about that opportunity to play for
the world championship in you know
disappointing unfortunately i didn't
really deserve it this time
yeah well thank you very much fabi good
luck for
the 14th and final round and
we'll look forward to seeing you when we
get a chance
thanks yesterday soon
all right we still have a game going uh
it is between kirill alexenko and dingle
iran we might as well jump
into that as it still has quite a bit of
action
uh yeah daleran had sacrificed two pawns
and kirill said give them take him
me like yes indeed knight d4 that is
i don't know if this was a move that uh
dinglaran expected or not but i mean it
to my way of thinking it's like the
first move you think of the rook
and the bishop and the queen are all
coordinating so let me
number one i'll take your rook off of
the square
and number two i'll hit the knight was
it was ding
expecting that knight d4 was unplayable
because of bishop
e5 if he had expected it guess what
knight takes f5
with a fork turns the table so
knight d4 and um
well ding loren's been in a tank
yeah well he's only been thinking for
seven minutes oh i'm sorry i'm missing
ah sorry yeah i would say it's a tank
though
because you're down two pawns right all
right
yeah you're down two pawns and the guy
just dropped a move that maybe you
thought he couldn't play
and if you're down two puns you should
have a move right now
right i mean you should i have a move
right i
i know what i was gonna do about a night
centralizing
and attacking my bishop directly uh i
did have a response for that
and if you don't have a response then
you start to feel a little bit of
discomfort no so what the problem with
bishop e5 i assume is
the queen a5 right that doesn't work no
knight f5 is yeah
mentioned also oh knight f5 yeah
that's good enough yeah um but
if the bishop has to drop back to d7
well i've got rook to e3 to stop
bishop uh e5 to begin with and there's
another move i mean
yeah i have one pawn i have two pawns
can i have a third pawn i mean
um it's getting very very serious for
the world's number three player here
well he's the number five
player i understand i mean but he
started the event
devil's advocate there after bishop d7 i
didn't particularly like rookie 3
because of queen f6
unless i'm missing something some issues
with
and left hanging in there's a pin i see
yes we know it's also kind of coming
yeah no i wanted to just
do everything in the nicest way that i
could
maybe in that case it my bishop where
should my bishop be bishop
what a move by dingley red bishop e4
what what
okay i have to take there's no choice
right i would resign if i don't take
okay and queen take and
running check no i'm just running the
night
the night i'm okay i was running the
night so if i go
i guess i have to defend the rogue d3
by the way he's the number four player
in the world
uh because theory lost gary's loss so
he's at number four no real chance to
catch jan at number three anymore
but man bishop to e4
all right that was a visual yeah i was
thinking about this whole time no reach
three c5 i guess i just take if i take
on d4 you take with
the rook you do have ideas of
c5 and queen e5 maybe
but i'll be down two pawns in many of
these variations right like for example
if i go c5
bishop takes c5 queen e5 yes you win the
bishop congrats but knight f3 i think
no knight of three queens oh knight f3
queen c3 and then
d1 that no that's fine knight g1
oh this is the yeah that's like jonathan
rousen versus guillermo move
knight g1 so that means queen e5 doesn't
work because knight of three my point
was that the c5 bishop takes c5 queen e5
no first c5 yes yeah yeah you take
you fork you go knight f3 but the point
is that if you take on c5
yes you got your piece back but you're
down two pawns
no you don't want this you don't want
this this is dead there's no entrance
dead right right so
group d3 does look kind of forced
it looks boxy yeah yeah
e5 queen what else could he bishop e5 it
has
has to be bishop b5 right because queen
f4 knight f3 leads
nowhere there's no back rank and i
always have knight chi wanna been
pointing out
i mean even if there was some oh no i
thought rook d4
but before rook d4 and you can't queen
b1
rook d4 i've got i've got that covered
yeah
you got that color so it's bishop e5 i
guess
what else can you do um
no let's see bishop e5 i guess and if i
just bishop c5
i attack that looks very natural
um i'm at peace up here really queen of
four
queen of four queen ah thank you
thank you uh with the threat of mate and
the knight of three f3
it's our first it's our favorite three
yeah right i mean bishop he's three
knight g5
it's kind of funny that the king is
suddenly uh
bishop v5 is on the board all right
bishop e5 so let's see bishop c5 queen
f4 is just that annoying
fascinating queen can't be
it can't be worth a piece no no no why
not
because it's
[Laughter]
a piece they're sideline pieces your
knight is pinned and your bishop is
doing nothing
and this is a direct attack but there is
king g1
like bishop c5 queen for king g1 just
saying it's a piece
and now you can chase and get the king
to go all
there's still a pin that looks slightly
annoying but it doesn't seem like it's
gonna last very long but here comes a
different
problem but this i can answer with
rookie three
yeah rookie three looks sufficient
um let me see i could the pin is on
right so i could play check and take on
g2
now this is oh
nice i don't believe it i don't believe
it
yeah that's a real piece okay no no this
this cannot be
it right so king g1 team g1 yeah
what's the problem with kg1 nothing
nothing
i was actually looking for for something
even
more of a refutation probably g3 is
ridiculous
and king g1 is the right move so there
you go king g1
doesn't seem right c5
c5 we're gonna have to find out guys
what's what's going on
and by the way i just saw the bar drop
really recipiently what what are we
missing there's a move we're missing
like four [ __ ] we're missing a
blunder and we're missing something
what bishop yes yes we're missing a move
so it's what could it be ruptured
no no that doesn't work i tried trust me
i tried
i'm all about traits after teaching
this louis chass team for as long as i
have yeah all i see now is tricks
it's that's one of the things that you
just practice
uh like like you just you're a drill
sergeant
you will learn your tactics is that is
that what coach good coach just do
just honestly with my particular team
we need it's just they're just tricks i
try to teach them strategical play
all they are is no no no they just want
more tactics huh
okay well this is it uh tactics guys
come on
because rook b8 does through b8 rook d1
repair i don't see what that does
yeah i mean hold on hold on rook be
working oh my god
how do you defend it queen f4 rook b1
and if queen d2 this is impossible but
my queen abner or
[Music]
leave the pin alone completely ignore
the pin on the d line
and play rook b8 who defends the back
ring rook d1 is the only move
queen cannot move because a queenie one
mate
or queen takes d3 yeah i'm saying like
like
c2 for example is not possible yeah
queen c1 hangs your rook so you have to
move your rook back you can't move your
knight because it's still pinned
and then one straight
background mating idea that is
unbelievable
and beautiful now you have to defend
this piece with the queen only way
the only move and now queen m4 a mate
and a
that's gorgeous that is that is
beautiful and enforcing it's amazing
how is this attack genius absolute
genius
this is the ding loren that we expected
to see play the whole candidates
wow so this whole thing works
extraordinary time
this whole bishop e4 thing worked that's
amazing
that sequence you still don't believe it
like like even
even when you okay you use this and
you're
in your lessons with your students and
you go okay guys
why black to move and win or what's
black's best move
even when you show them that bishop e4
works you don't believe
it they'll be asking for you well
alejandra how could that work
what laws allow that to work i guess he
should have played bishop d2
but then you have c5 right okay based on
of a pawn but it's a bad blockaded pass
queen
do something weird and we play on yeah
let's see listen you can see d4
[Music]
yet but i mean i i feel carol's pain i
mean
this young man you know we were just
kind of saying you know as
is maiden voyage and the uh candidates
getting that experience
you know prepping him for future events
welcome to the candidates like oh my god
that is just gorgeous all right i am
being told
i i am now cheating because sometimes i
get text messages
i am being told that there was a win for
kiril it was bishop b2 c5 and check this
out guys
bishop b2 c5n entertainment win here
yes queen is night moves knight
get the heck 96 looks amazing no it's
not 96. it's not 96
no it doesn't because i thought bishop
takes queen you have no but i take on d3
right
ah but if i take on d3 you take on e5
well
okay but then i'm losing last night was
it yeah yeah so that is
knight f3 it's knight f3 is knight after
[Music]
no more problems yep all
that's quite honestly even even bishop
c3 was winning at that point right
but knight g5 just finishes yeah yeah
not ever
okay so bishop b2 and what would have
happened after bishop b2
no c5 then he cries i think
no yeah that's amazing
i mean the bishop is
there's one of my favorite books
and i i it's such one of my favorites
that i had to make it
a a theme on my stream is the idea of
blunders
and brilliancies by moss and mo mo and
moss
one of my favorite books and the book is
all about how
one side plays a move that was a blunder
but potentially had a brilliancy they
could have played
and what they ended up doing is
overlooking a brilliancy of their
opponent
and this is one of those you could have
played bishop b2 with the idea of knight
f3
double x clamps himself and he said you
played bishop c5 and
rip v8 triple x clap
this is this is one for the for moen
boss
definitely and by the way that book is
hard to get now it's one of the best
books i've ever seen
and the book is like minimum 100 bucks
some places on ebay or whatever right oh
man i remember that right
it was some there was some position i
saw
it was like let's say black had a bishop
on d4 just for argument's sake
and a queen on d6 and somehow there was
a pin
but there was this move like bishop d4
to g1
you remember it exactly and the game was
actually with the queen on e5
okay d7 so the bishop on d4 was being
tortured
a knight on f5 queen on d3 rook on d two
and or maybe d one but the bishop on d4
is about to
die can't move can't black queen is on
him
the blackweed is defending it it can't
move
but and so he resigns in a moment when
bishop g
won threatening queen h2 mate and
luke takes queen on d3
that's like that's like the the the
first position in the book
yeah i remember i resigned he plays
bishop you could have played bishop g1
dude
what yeah i read whatever
that is again i bursted the laughter i
just thought that is just so
unfair just as cruel and the book is
full of those examples
oh wow it's full of them you should have
played this you would have won
but you're playing that and the guy
sacks is queen and you lost
oh i'm winning now you know and this is
and then
the guy plays a movie you go what
like here he covers everything possible
with bishop c5
what do you have you got nothing i got
it all covered and the guy moves away
from the d
line where there's another pin he's got
this double sweet cross pinning action
going on right and he leaves the file
and takes over another fight you're like
what's happening over there all right
you would think there's a defense right
there has to be
yes but exactly the best i can do
so far and i've looked at this position
for like five minutes now is bishop b4
bishop that's a response i think it's
the only way to keep material
it's a little depressing but it's not
super ideas maybe after c5
i was hoping queenie 1 worked queen e1
another one of those oh my god moments
yeah and then you take and i go knight f
like take take on e5
take on and they go knight f5 and i'm
saying
well i've been here with a chance i'm
here with the chance right
f-section petrol i don't see how i'm
against mate
that's impressive that's nice i try
so
c5 queen e1 queen d3
what was that maurice i'm sorry i just
want to know knight f5 i just want to
try to defend so knight f5 queen
b1 but if you if you're not killing me
i'm not down that much material right i
can play like queen eight take one f7 i
can take on c5
whoa just make your decision make one at
a time please
queen on c5 maybe if you take one f7 i
will have queen g3
queen e5 check if you play queen takes
on f7 so
uh this one maybe not the one you really
want to claim
right you're going to even nine even
though not the end of the world right i
go g3
[Music]
is challenging i mean come on yeah
because rookie one rugby one just died
it's unbelievable it's unbelievable it
died absolutely it dies
i'm still in some kind of like amazing
is that
yeah is that oh i mean
you know i'm a whole piece and a pawn to
the good right
and suddenly yeah let's see this before
because bishop before rook b4 is also
playable but then the knight gets back
to g1
yeah that's what i was hoping take on
before queen takes d3
knight f3 i think the only move you
check i go knight g1 i'm still depressed
because you can take on f2
but right but this is the least bad i've
found so far
wow that that white has to bail out into
a bad position
from being a whole piece up and saying
you're getting ready to sign my score
sheet
it's got that it's a huge turnaround oh
my word
that position there that's that's
critically and that looks
horrible material is equal in the night
sitting on g1
how bad guys is a position like this
i mean if i've got no no queen one
queen one mini one queen b3 queen you
won
i don't care about your position no
that's the thing
i i've been trying to make these things
work but they just die
it's like rook d1 rugby when you resign
there's no moves there
no you know amazing this is ugly bishop
b4 is is a move
that's the real deal don't look at that
but once the rook gets in
the lineup is vicious that's incredible
oh
queen but you know now we can
rationalize it after the fact uh
that is this this bishop on c5 is really
doing nothing
bishop e4 is insane and crazy and i'm
not going to try to rationalize it
you have to move your bishop you found
one of the most remarkable moves i've
ever seen
but the this bishop on c5
is really out of the way and doing it
right i agree
it's just you can see that it's just
doing zero
and so the fact that it's out of the way
and the night is pinned means that white
is actually down two pieces temporarily
temporarily dynamically right
dynamically your bishop's doing nothing
and unites doing nothing they just can't
move so they're out of the game
temporarily so the fact that black
overwhelms white
on the dark squares is not really
surprising
if the bishop is sitting on c5 but you
know that
this tactic that we're seeing
is gorgeous from both points of view i
mean
the the bishop refuting bishop c5
is fantastic but also you know refuting
the whole the whole concept with bishop
b2
and knight f3 it's a great equally
beautiful it's a great puzzle
you put it in front of a player right
choose between bishop c5 and bishop b2
right one wins one loses which one is
which
yeah right and why because it's like
if you find knight f3 and if you find
rook b8 and rook b1
you know okay i got a student this guy's
good
nice wow refutation to the idea
and knight f3 bishop b2 with the idea
knight f3 is amazing refutation
yeah yeah shutting down the b file i
need to play bishop b2
to shut down the b file what who would
have thunk that the b
file was your problem i mean it was the
it was the pin that was the problem no
and by the way a lot of people might be
watching and saying but don't you win
the rook
on d3 with some with some chances
and the answer is no because two pieces
for the piece is not even
or will overwhelm at all and especially
as you will lose this pawn so it will be
three versus two on the king side with a
rook for
the two pawns and a bishop at night for
the three pawns and that will be
all she wrote play rook a3 here for me
[Music]
and take
and rook c2 i think i'm just going to
win this guy
yeah this this is easily winning and
then takes
in this position so here a lot of
students would absolutely
say well this is not so bad it's bad
it's two pieces that's really bad
it's really really really bad oh my word
but what a turnaround
i'm still like in stunned
puzzlement amusement shock
actually like you know i'm curious wow
dingleran is such a such an elite player
and i would say somebody who cares about
the quality of his play
right uh there's some players who would
get this win and say
hey i gotta win nice well and it wasn't
as pretty
but there are some players like dan
lorenio say we've seen him even win
games we've seen him actually win games
that to us
look virtually flawless and he'll
downplay it
wow i know i got a little unsatisfied
yeah
what do you mean you you cream the guy
no you know i couldn't he had this
chance here
he could have maybe equalized but dean
loren
cares about the quality of his moves for
him it's not just
i won the game good for me i hustled the
guy
he could have played the other line
great big deal i somehow did it
no he cares about the quality of his
play and i'm going to say
when somebody tells him that bishop b2
was on the board
if he doesn't realize it already he's
not going to be
pleased with this victory he's going to
say yes i've been playing badly this
whole tournament
and that was another circumstance where
i made a mistake
in calculation and i could have and
maybe should have
lost the game and he's going to go back
home and say i've got a lot to fix if i
want to fight
for the world championship title which
you can best believe is his aspiration
he'll say i had a lot to fix uh guys i
got a good question for you right here
uh it's not like you're at a casino or
something like this but you're black
you're two pawns down and you can
smell the bacon uh it's your own
and then you see this move bishop e4 and
you think to yourself that can't
possibly work and you see
everything we've discussed you see that
after bishop e4
takes takes rook here bishop here
you you win when the guy goes bishop c5
but you lose when the guy goes bishop b2
you're now back at this moment do you
play bishop e4 alejandro yes or no
a lot of that question has to be
determined with the starting position
right how bad is it if i just retreat my
bishop
because if it's bad you just go bishop
before you gamble you say
well whatever but bishop d7 still gets
quite a bit of compensation
for me your thoughts do you gamble do
you say
oh it's just too beautiful i got to show
the world what i was thinking
i got to play bishop e4 i would never
play bishop e4
i just if i saw bishop b2 i'm sitting
there hoping
my opponent spots it my my professional
gm card has a clause on it that says
thou shall not play terrible moves if
you see your opponent can refute you
and make you look like an idiot after
you played it and then you go yes i saw
that
they'll say what do you mean you saw
bishop b2 yeah i saw he could play
bishop b2 i just went for it i just was
hoping
hope chess i tell my student no hope
chess no hope for you
battle the game why would you create a
position where one move you lose
when like alejandro said maybe you play
another move and it's still a fight
there's some comp
right i would not it's also possible for
myself and miss knight f3 right
yeah i think this is the most likely
scenario i don't think he saw it
he just would tell you instantly i
didn't see this move yeah i don't think
he saw bishop b2 and thought knight f3
he probably saw c5
probably thought c5 and he's fine these
retreating moves are very easy to stop
right and he just stopped and said good
for me
but knight of three at the end beautiful
yeah he might even have lost at 96 or
something
might have considered 96 or something
more direct but the knight is hanging
right that night is hanging
no i i just can't gamble like that it's
uh
it's a different kind of nature i'm not
i'm not a big gambler over the board but
i do know that there are some players
that say
let's go yeah alexis shearer for me was
was a great gambler uh he would you know
ramp
up you know when he could reduce the
tension or the
position and he just had this great
sense
of you know
keeping the tactics alive right but this
for me was just
i mean i i just haven't seen this kind
of
pattern where i mean i'm still reeling
that bishop c5 is refuted
and the thing is he saw this he saw rook
beat was winning
you don't go into this without us at
this level you he saw rick bead was
winning
it's kind of amazing that he saw this
from afar that bishop e4
absolutely the whole concept he had to
see from the beginning otherwise you
just play into this the guy goes bishop
c5 and you resign
he had to have a plan going into this
seeing the a1
think that rugby 8 wins here is
difficult seeing that rugby 8 wins
when you play bishop e4 wow
and again for those of you who may be
joining us late
it's even here where you
if you don't see black's next move you
resign
but black's next move wins the game it's
a remarkable move you go
queen here threatening mate
threatening the queen and in case of
queen takes you've got the swiss and
zoug rook takes d
one to one true is bishop f4 possible
here
i'm sorry what in what in this case
bishop f4
probably that looks really
really good too you also win the queen
there yeah i think this you don't even
know well this will be a fight but
actually it's not a fight because i
cannot take on b1
no you just yeah still got mated
oh my goodness so f3 would be forced
uh that's just the same
same yeah takes moves
completely so no that's not possible yes
so bishop four wins two
so he had a couple of wins back at the
end he just missed bishop b2
i like queen for best
and let's take a look at this hall of
fame
past winners of the candidates as we had
magnus carlsen of course famously
winning
in 2013 edging vladimir kramnik on the
tiebreaks he went on to become the world
champion defeating vishyanan
picking vanande he made a great comeback
in what a lot of people
said was a big surprise of 2014 when
vichy
let's be honest kind of dominated that
candidate he did
eight and a half points sergey karjakin
eight and a half points
in 2016 in moscow
surged i mean search at the end yeah i
mean we were all
at the end we all but popped the
champagne
in um st louis anticipating
that in 2016 fabby was going to win but
just at the very
last two rounds sergey
got the uh challenger spot by the way
looking at this list there is some
there's one commonality
by the way nepo's score of eight and a
half is pending it is pending because
he's got one more game
yeah nine or nine and a half but the the
one thing about this list
that it doesn't say is that
only one person remained the world
champion
despite all the candidates all right
everybody comes and goes
you could have had another you know you
could be all these candidates could be
the same but the person they're
challenging for the title
could have been different but after 2013
there's only one name that you're not
did you see on the other side of the
ledger
and it's mcmc fcmc
the champion has remained magnus carlsen
ever since he took the title
so never try to change that quick
question for you both
obviously since magnus
challenged for the world championship
title and won
the world championship title it's been a
short match dubai will be a longer match
how many games is the world championship
match in dubai
um today i saw something that said 24.
no and i was just believing i thought
that that was wrong
but i also saw something that was 16
and i just wasn't sure myself so i just
was hoping that you know
you knew by the way uh carol
probably coming to this horrifying
realization
that something is amiss has played your
move bishop before
alejandro because there was nothing else
in the position to do
rook d1 rook b1 loses for white so
but now now we have choices for black
right we could take on b4 we like that
c5 we were not entirely sure what
happens after queen e1
um we could also just play queen f4
right and
ask you how you're going to defend
against checkmate
second is queen f1
quinny why not rook takes b4
oh man that's gross i missed that
but i still have rookie three i still
have rookie three rookie three
okay okay one's not a miracle move right
oh man i'm finding them i'm finding this
miracle
like oh uh
oh man that's hilarious no no no no no
no hold on
i didn't see her sorry sorry i'm not
done rookie three queen g6
yeah but knight b3 that's a little too
fancy knight what
b3 knight to b3 oh yeah okay you're
right i thought i was on materials
to win back i understand i'm not up
material you
you you're ready to show me your rook b1
move here but okay in any case
bishop uh bishop b4 was
boss uh we weren't sure right yeah
i won rook takes b4 looks
yeah but but alejandro's knight f5 was
bothersome you had come up with
maybe maybe you know what also is
bothersome instead of
instead of uh knight f5 just queen eight
no leave the rook on the back rank i got
to move leave the bishop on b4
in this position oh no it doesn't work
sorry okay what i was going to do
i found a reputation for my reputation
what i was gonna do
you could go down the line see if uh it
was c5 queen e1
c5 queenie one right murray's gone
uh queen dude yes d3
queen e5 and you wanted to leave the
rook on the background guy
yes and protect everything and play
queen b1 check
aha so just what just move the rook
somewhere no no no no no
one immediately i want to do this oh
queen b1 champion against king h2
yeah ph2 i had the the devious queen
takes b4
guarding everything if you play knight
f5 i was going to play queen b2
but then i noticed nice c6 uh in the
position
yeah that's a 9. shut down my whole
thing so i said okay i gotta stop
that doesn't work because queen takes on
on baby to suddenly
wrecks my my fantasy so it doesn't work
so this is a sharp position
mull this over oh let's do it
extended analysis let's do it during a
break what do you say guys
yep let's take a quick break we'll be
back with the last
game of round 13. still plenty of action
left here for us
[Music]
when you visit st louis you'll probably
want to watch the cardinals or the blues
what about
after the game heading back to the hotel
would be a major
error instead boogie through the city
and discover the music that gave the
blues their name
at the national blues museum broadway
oyster bar or even the legendary
blueberry hill
so whether you love the cardinals the
blues or the blues
come play with us hey you guys know i
can't play this
right st lou is always exploring
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion of open
doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active communities
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear
when you really listen listening to you
caring for you we are ascension
be surprised be intrigued be
delighted the world chess hall of fame
in st
louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you
never imagined it's a one-of-a-kind
cultural institution
where rare artifacts and world-class art
play together
the world chess hall of fame mind art
experience
founded in 1839 the university of
missouri
is steeped in tradition the recently
founded mizzou chess program
is a partnership between the university
of missouri and the st
louis chess club collegiate chess has
been experiencing a meteoric
rise at the national level through its
tradition of excellence
mizzou has always strived for the best
mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar
by bringing our institution's ethos of
respect
responsibility discovery and excellence
to the chessboard
professional golf returns to st louis in
2021 the ascension charity classic
presented by emerson
stars like phil mickelson ernie else jim
furyk and more compete at norwood hills
country club september
6 through the 12th tickets clubhouse
passes hospitality suites and pro-am
foursomes are on sale now
all proceeds go to north st louis county
charities visit
ascensioncharityclassic.com
or call 314-938-2828
tour golf is back in the louvre the
ascension charity classic
[Music]
the st louis chess club is pleased to
announce the expansion of our
world-class chess facility
the 20 000 square foot expansion and
upgraded facility will feature new
ground-level classrooms supporting
players of all ages
as well as expanded tournament and
community gathering spaces with
state-of-the-art technology
accessibility upgrades including a new
three-story elevator
will provide access for all participants
and allow even greater community
engagement
in the great game of chess as a proud
resident of the central west end
neighborhood for over a decade
our hope is to build upon our investment
into the community
and solidify st louis as america's chess
capital and preeminent global
destination
for lovers of the sport we look forward
to seeing you in our new space in 2021
when we will host the 2021 u.s chess
championships 2021 u.s juniors and
senior championships
the sinkfield cup st louis rapid and
blitz and more
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome everybody we are back in what we
think will be the final portion
of round 13 of the candidates let's take
a look at the current standings there
you are
with the challenger 2 carls and it's
going to be jan nevonya
eight and a half points with a great
performance still one round to go
and you can say can't anish geary catch
that with a win and a loss by yan
yes he can catch him in the tournament
points but he cannot catch him in the
tournament standings
as crucially anisha has the worst
tiebreak against napo because of their
head to head
which means the tournament is
essentially over maxima sheila graf and
fabiano corona are currently tied for
third place grizzchook with a little bit
of a surge
on the last few days finds himself
at six and a half fifty percent wachow
dinglerand well not having the
tournaments of their lives and kirill
alexenko he's
trying to make the mark in his
tournament he's still playing against
lyran
but oh boy luck is simply not on his
side today
and we were analyzing some variation
during
the break and it seems like dingleran is
going
right into it yasser take us through
exactly we were
i mean black is spoiled for choice queen
f4
and the move that was played rook takes
b4
is a really really nice move we were
during the break we were looking at
queen takes
uh rook takes queen takes queen takes
back rank mate threat got a scurry to
bring the knight in the way and here
you're absolutely
hoping that white will play queen takes
black f2 black will play queen takes f2
protest queen on on the g3 square
uh threatening you with mate but then
you'll have the move knight f3 which
will defend everything
but uh dinglerin found the crushing blow
bishop to d4
in order to take with the bishop on f2
that makes all the difference in the
world
we were having some fun ourselves
looking
at a what do we call it maurice a
15 move variation where we reach here
and
you say to yourself can we make a
perpetual well we'll set up the pattern
so check to the king please go back to
g8 so i can go
queen here but no the king actually just
goes for a walk
all the way up the board
and we oh actually sorry it was an
important moment right here too
we could go queen f we could force the
quai
trait of queens but that actually loses
this is a
a terrible ending for by the way queen
of heaven
king e5 was better a little more precise
even though i think
i'm sorry yes yeah i don't know king e6
allows queen takes c6 check
ah yeah that would be nice yeah right
right that would have been a bad move
yes but we had seen a line like this
and we rejected it for uh
yeah as unacceptable and
so we were whoops excuse me let's just
go
here so we were looking at a variation
you can't play you have to play queen f4
queen f3 has been refuted by king e5
right this line you have to play and
hope that somehow you're still
checking this king forever but um
but we haven't gotten too we never tried
it's different because c5 you can take
with the bishop i think
as soon as the bishop moves the queen
controls too many squares right
for example c5 bishop takes c5 you don't
even have one chuck
so you have to play you have to keep
checking check
now you're in the mix and then you go
back
yeah we got you we got to go to b5 you
should go to b5 yes
yeah but we got to some position like
this right
where we where we managed to yeah but
you couldn't find it in one move you
went you went around
right after you took right here just go
to b5
right and you just do it like this and
then you go back
we got some position like this and we
said there was a good there wasn't going
to be any perpetual check
anymore and that was queen e5 check
we had to play king a6 before letting
this happen but this way is possible and
now
now it's time to pay the piper
yeah you have to you have to go into the
end game but that's hopeless
right we need to check trades off at the
end there as well but
up upon the bishop destroys the knight
easily and queen b8 already on the board
of course king h7 is the only move so
it's been played
uh dingle iron is the type of player
that just calculates it out right
you see the line no second thought
immediately took on f2 exactly
we are going to see this exact line play
itself out unless he resigns because his
last chance
is this perpet queen f5 check on the
board king up
on the board and we'll see all these
moves queen f4 check
the only check to play
and not g5 and blow everything uh
queen definitely not g5 now here comes
the king
marching over as this would just be g6
played
everything so kg6 instead played and
it's time to march the king
to the other side where there are pawns
that can shelter it
right and i doubt killer will resign
he'll keep
checking to see once you have a check
you don't resign right
yeah yeah exactly what your exponent
might do
i mean in in my my days of youth uh
i mean you you'd always go down with a
spike check
the last great act of defiance you
didn't you didn't resign when you got a
check on the board
by the way i'd make a point that i it's
an important point i think
that a lot of people a lot of books sort
of avoid
or don't talk about i don't know if you
guys have ever seen any books you can
tell me
if you have but i've never seen a book
that talked about the importance
of the check of check itself
right you just check that's all it is
it's it's just
a check it's a forcing move and you must
respond to it
and because what checks do what a check
will do you know when you're beginners
you play
bishop b5 check right i'm attacking the
king on e8 and then they play c6 and you
go
well i was dealing right yeah right and
so you learn not to waste your check or
just to play any old checks
but there are a lot of positions where
you start with a check
and it disrupts the opponent's position
something
happens your check didn't have any
single necessary meaning by itself
it's not forking any pieces there's no
skewer
action or anything like that you just
say check your turn
and when the because it's a forcing move
you have to do something about
check and then when you start looking
it's like oh wait a minute
wherever i put my king something bad's
gonna happen
after this check and it's what i call a
setup check
the check sets up some other kind of
known tactic
like the pin like a skewer some
interference tactic discoveries whatever
it is
but that setup check is important it
looks like it's
by itself it's harmless but it's what
follows
and so when you talk about a spike check
all right
if you just checked him i it wasn't my
fault he walked
where he was prepared with a tactic
right now my fault
just just a little check i i
i have the book i i don't recommend the
book at all i think
it almost ruined my my chest upon
power in chess but you're saying
something like
the power of the check and chess
book like that i i can't think of any
book uh
meeting what you've discussed yeah
what you discussed i mean there's so
many positions where your very first
check
is just a check there's there's we do it
all the time we save ourselves with that
you know you finish the tactic and then
i go oh check my queen came back
oh wow i didn't look at that right right
it was just a check
it just set up the next position so i
could launch from that
check to a different square that's much
more important
and i it's just something i've never
seen
in books tactic books you always see
things
based on the themes either the typical
tactics we talk about the pin the fork
the skewer and others or mating patterns
like the art of checkmate by renault and
somebody else i forget his name but you
know these are the checkmating patterns
these are the tactical themes but to say
it's just a check first it's just a
check
but watch what happens next because you
started with this check
it's not something i see discussed in
the literature
so interesting here and like you said
spike checks count
spikes just check it might be mate i've
heard that said
people check but a lot of times we teach
our students don't just check please
it's not right it's not a good idea
to just check but sometimes it is a good
idea to just
check this it's just a check but it
leads somewhere else
here it looks like it may lead nowhere
yeah the setup check i don't have a
better name i wish i had a more elegant
name but the setup nice it sets
up the next possibility who knows what
will happen next
well i can only imagine how badly carol
is feeling by the way
badly and with 40 seconds uh as i said
yes four moves to make so he has to
choose his chucks kind of carefully
it looks like we need two queen x4
king e6 yeah i mean i can just imagine
how badly he's feeling because
literally ten moves ago or a little
less more he was up two pawns
and declining draws and everything and
now he's in
an eternal pin and just hoping against
hope that he has a perpetual check
which we believe is not the case we
think he's actually just lost
actually he could even defend that
knight he's going to defend the knight
on the last move
with queen h2 no self-respecting
right no self-respecting grandma should
we
ever ever allow this position to appear
anywhere
near i think about not having any moves
i will play queen takes f2 long before i
play queen h2 bishop g3 that's terrible
oh boy uh queen e4
check on the board expecting can he just
dance
another way away i mean there's
there's no need uh but why why find
another we found one win
but king d7 queen f5 worries me why
um the next check is a5
well that's nice i mean that's great get
get get yourself over there
no i don't want the queen on that side
well what's wrong with it
well i was thinking if you go down
maurice that i would just get you
to get this and i would say queen a5
but king well then i guess
we would eventually get maybe back to
our
yeah i think they'll ran what is this
nonsense king d6 immediately
immediately queen f4 back king c5
immediately of course the
iron has foreseen all hide in front of
the pawns that's what you do
yeah go hide in front of the other
players pawns
or you get your bishop back in the game
i mean this is what you
you would normally do although here with
with king the immediate king b4 is met
by queen b2 check
right so the idea of hiding in
inside of your opponent's pawns is a
very typical idea
it's not the cleanest hiding's place
there
but if you can take a pawn in the
meantime on c4
and then bring your pieces that are
beautifully diagonally placed
back to help bishop drops back maybe
your queen might drop back in the way
then when you trade off into the end
game you're just looking at
the the burning embers the ashes
remaining of your poor position
as you were once up two pawns you said
yes
yeah two funds
[Music]
with your knight pinned on the back ring
you're king of grumbling in the corner
and i feel so physically helpless at
these
uh eternal pins and he's taking the pawn
and he's like yeah
now i'm up and you're still pinned and
there's not going to be a perpet
so queen f4 is the only move right
because queen e4 runs into bishop d4 and
that kind of helps black
are you sure sorry sorry sorry i forgot
c6 is hanging
yeah yeah yeah my bad so either way your
first back to b5
right
the problem he has played queen e4 king
b5
a4 doesn't don't go into the end game
that's plus
a4 king moves
no you'll hide on a3 right you can just
kind of see it
yeah and even maybe when there's a check
and you're on a3 you'll go c5 and that
bishop
on f2
is he might even take it eventually and
then his queen and bishop are ready to
back up and cover
my good i mean i just feel the pain i
just can't imagine how
how badly carol is feeling at this exact
moment as
i mean he declined to draw he's playing
for the win
for much of the game and to reach this
position
is just heartache
king b5 on the board
yeah i don't see a4 when i think of a
particularly
bad losses the the this one was probably
a bad one
you guys you guys remember what is
your worst loss where you had a big turn
around
like this uh alejandro share share the
the demons i've had pretty bad ones i
think the worst one
ever was that needing a draw to clinch
the final four for collegiate chess
yeah against uh crits
i was what happened oh okay and
all i needed was a draw and the team
clinches and
i think by the way thing has won
alexenko has resigned
he has resigned i simply left the piece
hanging like i was up oh
i was a position in which it was two
pawns against one knight and rook
against bishop and rook
and i'm pressing i have two pawns i
can't lose
and he attacked my rook and i didn't
move it and he took your rock and he
took it
and you didn't make the final four no
wait that was the final of the final
four
oh that was the final of the final four
okay that hurt you'll carry that with
you for the next 20 years for sure
for sure so i'm counting them off
we we uh we had four decisive
uh games in round 12. we've had
three decisive games in round 13.
guys uh league
lengthy tournament whatever it is we're
seeing a lot of victories in these
last few rounds a lot of action for sure
yes sir
are you not entertained look at this
great games
feeling for kiril alexander's first
showing here but
welcome to the big leagues right you
can't make him look like bishop c5 and
think that he didn't have a plan
what a cold shower rook b8 was for their
young russian
but it's okay russia is celebrating jan
pomnyacci
in the world championship match i mean
we said coming into the tournament nepo
nepo he's one of the leaders
he's been playing well he's mercurial he
could lose three in a row
but he didn't do that this tournament he
kept his cool kept his composure he kept
his stability
and now he's number three in the world
and challenging magnus carlsen
i thought that was a particularly
insightful comment
of fabi when he said that this one year
break
actually favored nepo
as he was wobbly he lost that game seven
and that one-year break helped him
here's our pairings for tomorrow yeah
bearings for tomorrow
uh was throw a tournament left so yeah
there's still a round to go we have
fabiano carano with the white pieces
against alexander grizzchuk and i'm sure
that fabi will try to win
uh that game aneesh giri will be trying
to secure his second place by beating
alex
alexenko ding lyren with the white
pieces
well i don't think this game is going to
be the most dramatic against janna
pognachi
and maxine macher legroff with the white
pieces against wang hao to finish off
the event
tough to play tomorrow honestly i'll win
by dingler in by the way we put him back
at number three in the world so i don't
know if that's any motivation for him
he's also gained rating points this half
of the tournament
as badly as we were saying he was doing
he's actually gained rating points he
had beaten maxine
as he should have yeah uh he would have
been having a great event
by the way
definitely would have been in a
different setting and uh
but again motivation how do these
players play the last day
when they already know the event is over
there was only one goal
and one player has met that goal these
players play for the title that's what
they do
so to come tomorrow and say i really
really really
want to be you personally
you gotta come in with a check on your
shoulder i don't like
you you're going down i know it doesn't
matter but you're going down
that's got to be the attitude uh to i
don't think they'll be doing that i
think
as you mentioned before uh alejandro
probably they probably try to book an
early could i get an early flight would
you mind
because if i get early fight home i need
to get out of here i don't want to be
here anymore
all right but we will be back tomorrow
absolutely we'll be back same time same
place early tomorrow we have four more
brilliant games of chess
do not miss them the players are still
fighting for pride for money for raiding
and we'll see it all take action
thank you for sharing your day have a
good one
[Music]
you